Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim. Gold. Nein, nein, nein, du darfst keine Frage stellen. Nein, du darfst keine Frage stellen, nein. Ruhe. Nein, Fake News, du bist Fake News, anderer bitte.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundsechs. Und wir leben immer noch in einer freien Welt, in der jeder das Recht hat, seine Meinung zu sagen und äh die Fragen zu stellen, die er gerne möchte, oder?
Buchen, die ihr gerne haben möchte.
Goldene Zeiten auf jeden Fall. Goldene Zeiten.
Fragetickets werden verteilt, ne? Man kann nicht einfach Fragen stellen hier, da muss man sich erst ein Ticket holen.
Genau, vor allem wenn man bettelt gar nicht mal mehr nur um Antworten, sondern man muss schon darum bitten, überhaupt fragen zu dürfen. Das ist schon äh wirklich sehr interessant,
Ja, hier äh sind wir wieder äh relativ pünktlich. Genau eine Woche später und ähm haben uns auch gleich mal den ersten Gast eingetreten hier dieses Jahres, nämlich den Ulf Ulf Burmeier.
Eingetreten, einge.
Ja.
Nee, man man tritt sich nicht ein, weil's äh schon fast nicht äh vermeidbar war auf dich zu kommen bei der Gastwahl
da du ja so viel Aktivitäten entfaltet hast und das ist halt, die wir ja dann hier auch mal aufgreifen müssen, die wir auch schon aufgegriffen haben und jetzt aber auch nochmal im genaueren aufgreifen möchten.
Ja, vielen Dank, ich bin gerne da.
Ulf Burmeier bekannt aus bekannter eigentlich von uns, du hast, du warst zuerst bei uns im Podcast. Wir haben dich groß.
Wir haben dich, wir haben dich bekannt gemacht, vergiss das nie.
Genau. Vergiss nicht, wo du herkommst, mein Junge.
Und äh ähm als Podcast dabei der Lage der Nation seit achtunddreißig Folgen jetzt auch äh wöchentlich aktiv. Ihr schafft das auch glaube ich noch.
Ja, minus die Sommerpause. Die haben ja, wir haben ja acht Wochen, glaube ich, Sommerpause gemacht, aber sonst ja. Mhm.
Jetzt weißt du mal wie das ist.
Zusammen mit zusammen mit Philipp Banse ein Politikpodcast äh mit hohem Niveau.
Und äh um dieses Niveau ein bisschen auf uns abfärben zu lassen, äh wollen wir heute mit dir sprechen über die Verfassungs
Beschwerde die neueste Verfassungsbeschwerde aus dem Hause der GFF. Ähm das war ja also die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte wurde ja schon vor einiger Zeit gegründet und dann war es ja ähm
zunächst mal noch längere Zeit still, ne? Irgendwie auch gar nicht öffentlich gemacht, dass es
gibt und dann ähm habt ihr ich glaube also gefühlt hm das war schon über ein Jahr oder?
Ja, das waren, das waren sogar vierzehn Monate, weil wir so quasi im Steve Mode unterwegs, ne? Also du wusstest ja schon länger Bescheid, aber ähm genau, wir haben den Verein gegründet, Mitte September zweitausendfünfzehn
und dann kamen überraschend viel Orgafu, man muss ja keine Ahnung, man muss ein Konto eröffnen, das Ganze eintragen, Gemeinnützigkeit beantragen und so, das war schon relativ viel und wir hatten außerdem die Idee, ähm,
Wir wollen das jetzt nicht machen, wie die Krautreporter mit einer schönen Idee, einen Crowdfunding starten und dann mal schauen, was draus wird, sondern wir haben gesagt, wir liefern erst
und sagen dann so Leute, guckt her, wir haben jetzt was geliefert und wenn ihr das gut findet, dann wäre es klasse, wenn ihr in Zukunft dabei seid,
Und deswegen haben wir ähm quasi in aller Stille die ersten Verfahren vorbereitet, die ersten Klagen vorbereitet
und ähm und sind an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen, als wir wirklich die erste fertig hatten im November mit äh das war ja die Verfassungsbeschwerde, die wir zusammen mit Amnesty gemacht haben gegen das G zehn dieses Internetüberwachungsgesetz.
Und jetzt geht's gegen das Anti-Wissen-Blower-Gesetz, wie man so schön sagen kann. Eigentlich ist ja nicht ein eigenes Gesetz, sondern ein Passus in in dem Vorratsseitenspeicherungsgese.
Da fängt da fängt's ja im Grunde schon an, ne? Das ist finde, das ist so, das hat sowas Schlüpfriges, sowas unseriöses, ne? Da gibt's also dieses Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz, was immer man davon,
will, ja? Sagen wir das mal ganz neutral. Ähm, aber da hinten dran geklebt,
wurde dann eben noch eine Ergänzung des Strafgesetzbuchs durch den Bundestag geschmuggelt, die aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls inhaltlich nur sehr, sehr wenig zu tun hat mit der Vorortsansprachung, wenn überhaupt.
Also gibt's da irgendeinen Bezug, den man dann nehmen könnte.
Also ich sehe,
keinen, ich hab auf Twitter oder irgendwo wahnsinnig, habe ich dann mal die Idee gelesen, man könnte sich ja vorstellen, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung führt ja, wie man weiß zu riesigen Daten, Bergen, die bei irgendwelchen Providern im Keller hoffentlich gut gesichert liegen.
Die dann weitergegeben werden.
Wenn die dann weitergegeben werden, wäre das ja vielleicht ein Datenhederei. Und äh das hat irgendjemand mir so erklärt, dass das dann eine Art Schutzmaßnahme ist für diese höchstsensiblen Datenberge bei den Providern.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so eine Antwort auf eine der Standard äh Vorwürfe gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dass wenn diese Daten halt erstmal vorliegen, sie ja dann zwangsläufig auch irgendwie entweichen wollen,
ne? So ein bisschen wie Helium, Helium im Tank, ne? Das geht dann irgendwie auch noch durch die Ängste äh Ritze. Äh was ja ein berechtigtes Argument auch ist so, ne? Und dann äh haben sie sich eben diesen ähm ja, Fall des,
der Datenhelerei ausgedacht. Genau. Gab's diesen Begriff vorher so schon in der Rechtsprechung? Ist der schon mal.
Also ich hatte noch nie gehört, der ist erstmals aufgetaucht, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe in einem Gesetzentwurf aus dem Land Hessen, das Land Hessen äh beglückt uns ja unter seiner äh CDU-Justizministerin mit einer ganzen Reihe von skurrilen Gesetzentwürfen,
können wir vielleicht nachher noch ganz kurz auf den digitalen Hausfriedensbruch eingehen, ja? Ja, das ist leider kein Witz, ihr Lieben, das ist.
Ja, aber wir wollen nicht abschweifen. Äh das, wie soll ich sagen, soweit ich das in Erinnerung habe? Das
Produkt, ja, dieses Qualitätsherstellers war ähm eben die die Datenhederei, die allerdings am Anfang noch ein kleines bisschen,
enger gefasst war. Also am Anfang ging's tatsächlich vor allem darum, was ja offiziell auch der Grund für die Datenhederei war zunächst mal nämlich den Handel mit
gestohlenen Kreditkarten, Daten und Login-Daten äh quasi nochmal unter Strafe zu stellen. Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von strafrechtlichen Hebeln, wie man da auch jetzt schon reinkommt oder auch bevor es die Datenhederei gab, aber man wollte etwas nochmal so richtig klar machen, dass also richtig, richtig, richtig böse. Ähm.
Auch wenn man quasi jemanden mit Daten erwischt, aber nicht so richtig weiß
wurde die Daten einklärt, dass mit gestohlene Daten, ne? Das war so ein bisschen die, genau wie beim beim Hehlen auch. Also keine Ahnung, der erwischt jemand mit irgendeinem gestohlenen Fahrrad und der sagt, Jöde kann ich doch nicht wissen, dass das gestohlen ist. Ich hab's auch nicht gestohlen. Und dann war es in der, wo hast du's denn her? Na, vom Flohmarkt und was hat's gekostet, einen Zehner?
Ja? Und das ist so der klassische Fall, wo man dann jemanden unterstellen würde, na, das Rad ist achthundert Euro wert. Du hast es für einen Zehner gekauft,
Er will zu uns erzählen, dass du nicht gewusst hast, dass das geklaut ist, ne? Das ist ja quasi so die die Idee, wieso ist die klassische Hillerei überhaupt
ne? Weil man häufig Beweisprobleme hat, wo kommen die Sachen her und na genau und äh der selbe Gedanke war das ursprünglich auch bei der Datenhelerei, ähm zumal ich sage, okay, man erwischt da jemanden mit zwei Gigabyte Login Daten und er sagt,
keine Ahnung, wo die her sind und ich habe auch nichts Böses vor. So und da diese diese Beweisprobleme wollte man ursprünglich dadurch,
beheben, dass man gesagt hat, wir stellen jetzt einfach nochmal den Umgang mit gestohlenen Daten extra unter Strafe. Das war die Grundidee aus Hessen und ähm da gab's dann eine relativ
bunte Diskussion und die kamen aber dann zu so einer Art Stillstand und dann hat man sich anscheinend bei Gelegenheit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung überlegt, ist doch eine super Sache. Da stellen wir jetzt einfach einen Sachzusammenhang her und sagen, das schützt doch auch die Vorratsdaten davor, dass sie irgendwie auf Abwege geraten
und äh packt das in ein gesetztes Paket.
Na ja, wenn das sich jetzt aber nur auf die, genau, wenn sich das nur auf die Vorratsdaten bezogen hätte, dann hätte man diesen äh diesen Paragraphen aber ganz anders äh formuliert, oder?
Ganz genau.
Also der ähm vielleicht nur um das nochmal in Erinnerung zu rufen, ähm was Deutschland ja viele Jahre
beschäftigt hat, war der Umgang mit sogenannten Steuer-CDs.
Das war 'n Thema der öffentlichen Debatte, Steuer-CD geht folgendermaßen, du arbeitest bei irgendeinem bei irgend so einem Anbieter für für ähm
für Steuersparmodelle oder der auf den Seeschellen oder sowas sitzt ähm.
Oder auch in der Schweiz.
Oder in der Schweiz, ne? Und du, also du arbeitest quasi bei einem, sagen wir mal bei einem Anwalt oder Finanzdienstleister, der viel mit ähm,
mit Steuerhinterziehern zu tun hat und eben die Modelle äh in sogenannten äh Steuerparadiesen äh Geld zu sparen und irgendwie wegzuschaffen,
gestaltet und ermöglicht, sondern hast du uns Kundenverzeichnis, dann nimmst du dir eine CD, brennst das Kundenverzeichnisamt und erzogener Kohle dadrauf ähm und gibst das irgendwie bei den deutschen Steuerfahnen dann ab. So geht Steuer-CD. Ähm jetzt hast du aber natürlich ähm mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit gegen
da die Privatsphäre und Datenschutz deiner,
Kunden deiner ehemaligen Kunden verstoßen und natürlich auch gegen alle möglichen Geheimhaltungsvereinbarungen mit deinem Arbeitgeber hattest,
und jetzt ist die Frage, was machen jetzt die Steuerfahnen? Dann nehmen die diese CD und sagen alles klar, herzlichen Dank, jetzt jetzt wird jetzt machen wir Inkasso.
Oder sagen die, oh nee, das ist aber jetzt geklaut und äh das dürfen wir nicht, äh das dürfen wir nicht machen
das dürfen wir nicht nehmen. Und es gab jahrelange lebhafte Diskussionen, so wie ich das zumindest erinnere, äh weil man eben sagte, nein, der Staat, als als Krimineller, ne, der der Staat hier mit gestohlenen Daten kann.
Der Staat als Hehler auch, ja? Da kam's ja auch. Genau, der Staat als Datenheder.
Wie ist er, wie ist da eigentlich die, wie ist da eigentlich die Lage im Moment bei bei solchen Sachen? Ist das noch ähm wie wird sowas im Moment abgefrühstückt, wenn man so eine Steuer, wie wird, wie geht,
Gibt's das noch? Wie wie geht der, wie gehen wir gesetzlich damit gerade um? Was ist eben oder rechtlich? Was ist da gerade Practice?
Also da muss man sagen, ist in der Tat die Datenhelerei ähm jetzt mal wirksam geworden, denn
die Datenhederer würden natürlich den Umgang mit diesen Steuer-CDs auch unter Strafe stellen. Sie enthält aber eine glasklare Ausnahme für
Leute, die diese Daten-CDs ankaufen und bei einer Behörde arbeiten, ne? Da, das ist also das Einzige, was einem dem Strafgesetz wirklich klar ist, es würde die Steuer-CDs erfassen, es erfasst sie dann aber doch nicht, weil es eine
Ausnahme gibt, eine sogenannte Privilegierung, die die braven Steuerfahnder schützt,
Und an der Stelle ist das Gesetz auch wasserdicht, muss man ehrlicherweise sagen. Und damit ist ähm das Thema Daten-CDs durch, weil die bisherigen unklaren Rechtsfragen dadurch äh beantwortet sind.
Ah okay, das heißt nebenbei wird diese Unklarheit dann tatsächlich mal beseitigt, weil man sagt, ja, ist strafbar, aber nicht für ah okay.
Aber dann da eben doch nicht, ne? Und dann sagt man das, äh, da gibt's quasi ein spezielles Gesetz, nämlich die Datenhähnerei, die würde das eigentlich erfassen, sagt dann aber zugleich, äh dass das Gesetz eben nicht gelten soll für Amtsträger, wie das so schön heißt, Amtsträger oder deren Beauftragte,
denen Daten ausschließlich der Verwertung in einem Besteuerungsverfahren, einem Strafverfahren oder einem Ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren zugeführt werden sollen,
Und damit ist klar, das Gesetz würde es erfassen, sagt dann aber, ist doch nicht strafbar und damit sind alle anderen, sagen wir mal rechtlichen Konstruktionen, die das möglicherweise strafbar machen könnten, auch zugleich abgefrühstück.
Okay, aber jetzt äh ich war, ich weiß, du kannst es wie kein anderer erklären, welcher Tatbestand genau mit dieser Datenhelerei erfasst wird, weil das sind äh so drei Hops
in den in dem Text dies dies haben wir dies sehr schwierig machen diesen Paragraphen auf Anhieb zu passen.
Ja, das ist sehr lustig, weil ja selbst der Bundesminister für Justiz und für Verbraucherschutz daran gescheitert ist. Also man kann sich da einen sehr schönen Videoschnipsel angucken, vielleicht suchen wir den auch raus. Äh von der Bundestagsrede, ne? Also es gab ja
wenig öffentliche Diskussionen über die Datenhederei im Vorfeld, wie gesagt, weil sich ja die Aufmerksamkeit völlig auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung konzentriert hat
auf das große Paket und damit die Datenhelereise ein bisschen unter dem Radar flog. Aber in zwei, drei Sätzen ist Heiko Maas in der Bundestagsrede zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch auf die,
Helerei eingegangen und da ähm merkt man sehr deutlich, dass er äh im Grunde sein eigenes Gesetz nicht verstanden hatte oder ihm seine Referenten irgendwas irreführendes aufgeschrieben hatten, höchstwahrscheinlich. Ähm weil Heiko Maaßen mich sagt, Leute
riecht euch doch nicht so auf, das ist überhaupt keine Gefahr für die Pressefreiheit, die Wissel-Blower machen sich ja auch nicht strafbar. Und man muss zugeben,
Das ist in aller Regel wahrscheinlich wirklich so. Was worum geht's beim Whistleblowing? Wir stellen uns mal vor, da gibt's eben so einen Ministerialbeamten, ja und der hat äh und der hat ein schlechtes Gewissen bei irgendwem, was in seiner Behörde passiert. Keine Ahnung,
Ist ja ganz egal. Ähm irgendeine irgendein problematischer Sachverhalt und dann sagt er sich, das sollte die Öffentlichkeit wissen und er zieht die Informationen auf den USB-Stick,
und gibt die
direkt einem Journalisten weiter. Dann macht sich dieser Beamte strafbar, allerdings nicht nach der Datenhelerei, sondern wegen äh Verletzung von Dienstgeheimnissen normalerweise.
Und der Journalist ähm wäre jedenfalls bisher nicht strafbar gewesen, es sei denn, er hat den Beamten dazu angestiftet, ja, Anstiftung zur Verletzung von Dienstgeheimnissen ist strafbar, aber wenn er einfach nur einen USB-Stick nimmt und dann auswertet, war das bislang,
keine Straftat. Das Problem ist, ähm, wenn es jetzt einen weiteren Hopp gibt, also nicht nur von den Beamten, zum Journalisten, sondern von dem Journalisten zu irgendwem anders
dann entsteht das Problem bei der Datenhilderei, weil die Datenhilderei eben voraussetzt, dass die Daten schon einmal,
auf rechtswidrige Weise weitergegeben worden sind. Also zum Beispiel diese diese Weitergabe von den Beamten an den Journalisten. Das wäre die rechtswidrige Weitergabe. Im ersten Schritt noch keine Datenhederei, aber die Daten sind dann so quasi verbrannt, wenn man sowieso irgendwie so ja die Daten sind dann heiß
wenn man so will, weil sie einmal rechtzündig weitergegeben worden sind. Und wenn das einmal so war, dann können sie in Zukunft Gegenstand einer Datenhederei sein,
Um beim Beispiel zu bleiben, der Journalist gibt die Daten jetzt weiter.
Zum Beispiel an ein Mitglied des Chaos-Computerclubs und sagt, pass mal auf, ähm schau dir doch mal diese Daten an, da müssen wir jetzt mal jemanden mit IT-Sachverstand draufgu
lassen, keine Ahnung, um Metterdaten aus den PDFs zu polen oder was weiß ich irgendwas, was der Journalist nicht selber kann. Und dann ist spätestens dieser CC äh Mitarbeiter, dieser IT-Sachverständige dran, weil er sich,
verschafft, die vorher mal Gegenstand zum Beispiel an der Verletzung von Dienstgeheimnissen waren. Das ist so ein bisschen das Schwierige an dem an dem Gesetz, es ist im Grunde so ein Dreiecksverhältnis ist. Du hast den Whisleblower, du hast dann einen Mittelsperrson, zum Beispiel einen Journalisten und du hast dann
Experten, den der Journalist aber braucht und der spätestens ist dann dran. Aber auch der Journalist selber kann dran sein eben wegen Weitergabe dieser Daten.
Ähm in der Redaktion. Das wäre ein weiteres Beispiel oder ähm,
Ja genau, das ist so ein klassisches Beispiel. Du brauchst immer Weitergaben an verschiedene Personen oder auch Veröffentlichungen, können natürlich auch schon reich.
Also einmal, ja, es muss einmal illegal weitergegeben worden sein, nur einmal eine Gesetzesverletzung stattgefunden haben und dann, wenn es dann nochmal geht, dann bist du dran.
Genau, also genau, das ist wirklich, es ist wirklich ein bisschen Weard, ne? Also, man kann sich so ein bisschen am äh an diesem Wortlaut entlang hangeln. Wer Daten.
Die an andere durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, macht sich da möglicherweise strafbar,
Whisle Blower an den Journalisten hat der Journalist durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt. Und der Journalist muss dann ein anderer sein für den für den Datenhehler. Zum Beispiel der IT-Sachverständige, weil dann eben der Journalist der andere ist. Man muss da mal ein bisschen genauer hingucken, aber es lassen sich im
ganz normalen journalistischen Alltag reihenweise Fälle konstruieren ähm wo eben auch Journalisten sich danach strafbar machen. Weiter äh weiteres Problem.
Ähm, es gibt eine Ausnahme für Journalisten in diesem Straftatbestand.
Eigentlich sollen die geschützt sein, das war nicht von vornherein so vorgesehen, also von vornherein in dem ersten Entwurf stand nur dieses Privileg drin für die Steuerfahnder und für andere Ermittler,
und dann haben wir das verbloggt auf Netzpolitik und haben gesagt, hey, dieses Gesetz, was ihr da gerade schreibt, ist Brandgefährlich für die Pressefreiheit,
Und ähm dieser Artikel ist auch im Justizministerium gelesen worden, das haben wir wissen wir durch eine EFG Anfrage, also wir haben uns mal die Materialien kommen lassen zu dem Gesetz und da hat dann die Pressestelle Alarm geschlagen, gesagt, hier.
Das lässt sich aus diesen Daten rauslesen, dass die den Artikel gelesen haben. Ja, ja. Warum? Habt ihr die Browser-Historie da als EFG Anfrage?
Nee, ähm die haben, die haben das ausgedruckt, ähm natürlich, ja, die haben den Netzpolitikbeitrag ausgedruckt und äh,
Und den haben sie dann mit einer begleitenden E-Mail an die Hausleitung geschickt. Und dann sieht.
Damit ist der sozusagen Aktenkundig.
Da hat Herr Wohlmeier was geblockt auf Netzpolitik, klingt nicht gut, äh schaut euch das mal an und daraufhin hat dann Heiko Maas so steht's in dem, in dem, in den Akten drin, wahrscheinlich Heiko Maas, das heißt nur,
ja? M hat, ja? Aber ich geh mal davon aus, das ist jetzt nicht der Chef von null null sieben, sondern das wird in diesem Fall vermutlich Minister heißen. Ja, M sagt,
Möglicherweise, also entweder Maß oder Minister, ja, der Himmel weiß es, auf jeden Fall.
Was hat Q gemacht.
Was heißt Q gemacht, genau. Quatsch, klein, klein, Raketenwerfer, Kulli dafür gebastelt. Nee, ähm
Ich denke, ich denke, es wird Heiko Maas heißen und der hat im Grunde gesagt, Leute, hm, guckt euch das mal an, äh klarstellen oder auch das Gesetz ändern, eben geben.
Und äh dann ist das wieder auf dem Tisch gelandet von einem Referenten, der schon den ersten Entwurf geschrieben hat und der hat so reagiert, wie viele Leute leider reagieren, die keine gute Fehlerkultur haben, Scheiße
Ich kann doch nichts falsch gemacht haben und hat dann so Minimaländerungen vorgenommen und hat eben eine Ausnahme für Journalisten ins Gesetz geschrieben, die aber eben ultraeng ist. Und da gibt's vor allem zwei Probleme. Das eine Problem ist, dass die Ausnahme nur gilt
Für Handlungen, die ausschließlich journalistisch sind. Also ausschließlich der Erfüllung rechtmäßiger dienstlicher oder beruflicher Pflichten dienen. Das heißt also,
Sobald ich nicht mehr nur als Journalist dran bin, weil ich darüber schreiben will, sondern zum Beispiel, weil ich auch als Staatsbürger das doof finde oder keine Ahnung, wenn ich als Journalist über Antifa-Themen schreibe,
weil ich das auch, weil ich persönlich auch in der Antifa bin, also sobald ich irgendein persönliches Interesse an dem an dem Thema habe, was nicht nur dienstlich ist,
gilt diese Ausnahme nicht mehr für mich. Und das zweite Ding ist, was ist denn mit Journalisten, die nicht beruflich arbeiten? Ne, also,
Bei Leuten beim Spiegel ist das kein Problem. Bei den Festangestellten Netzpolitikleuten vermutlich auch noch nicht. Also André und und Markus und so, die da Geld mit verdienen, denen wird man schon sagen können, dass das ein Beruf ist, aber was ist denn mit Leuten, die so hobbymäßig bloggen bei Netzpolitik?
Ne? Sind das dann auch berufliche Pflichten? Dürfen die da ja nicht mehr mit
Daten arbeiten und was ist mit den Leuten die gelegentlich mal helfen bei Netzpolitik? Also ich zum Beispiel kriege überhaupt kein Cent von denen, gelegentlich aber kriege ich,
Daten von denen und soll dann dazu eine rechtliche Einschätzung abgeben. Wäre in Zukunft nicht mehr möglich. Genauso.
Eben auch möglicherweise für Anwälte, mit denen jetzt Politik zusammenarbeitet
denn da kommt jetzt ein nächstes Problem rein, ja rechtmäßige dienstliche oder berufliche Pflichten, das wird von der Rechtsprechung so ausgelegt, dass
Pflichten, nur Dinge sind, die man tun muss. Als Anwalt habe ich aber keine Pflicht mit PDFs zu arbeiten, die gelegt sind. Ich darf das vielleicht und es ist auch total sinnvoll für meinen Job
Ich hab aber keine Pflicht, da sind also schon Anwälte verurteilt worden, die ähm angebliche Kinderpornos an Sachverständige weitergegeben haben, um die
äh quasi ähm neutral analysieren zu lassen und diese Anwälte sind hinterher verurteilt worden, wenn man gesagt hat, du hast mit Kinderpornos gedealt und dann sagt er, ja hör mal, ich war doch hier Verteidiger, ich musste das doch analysieren lassen, ob das überhaupt Kinder, Pornos sind, ich kann doch nicht einfach glauben, was die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt und dann sagt das Gericht, nö
musst du nicht. Du darfst sie vielleicht weitergeben, ist aber keine Pflicht. Ja, nirgendwo steht, du musst die weitergeben. Bumstata, keine Pflicht im Sinne des Gesetzes also strafbar,
Kein Witz, es kannst du nachlesen, ich kann, ich kann dir die Fundstelle raussuchen, steht in unserer Verfassungsbeschwerde drin. Und deswegen, diese, dieses, das ist das Perfide an dem,
auf den ersten Blick denkt man ist alles überhaupt gar kein Problem und sobald du anfängst zu stochern macht es überall bumm bumm bumm.
Und deswegen habt ihr euch jetzt dagegen gewendet. Ähm ich habe, ich war überrascht, du hast gerade schon die Verfassungsbeschwerde ähm erwähnt, die der, die ihr jetzt habt, einreicht, äh die ihr jetzt eingereicht habt
hundertachtunddreißig Seiten PF, wenn ich das äh richtig äh in Erinnerung habe.
Das ist etwas länger geworden. Wir haben die, wir haben äh ja, also das ist sowieso.
Was länger. Das ist irgendwie eine, das ist eine Doktorarbeit vom.
Ja, na klar, das ist also das ist eine, das ist eine Doktorarbeit in der Tat, aber ähm.
Vom Umfang her oder hat die jetzt tatsächlich hat jetzt, weil du jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, vom Umfang, vom Umfang.
Jemand eingereicht und gesagt, alles klar.
Also sagen wir so, sie ist zehn Seiten länger geworden durchs Umformatieren für die Veröffentlichung, weil wir eine Kopf- und Fußzeile eingebaut haben mit und so mit dem Link auf die, auf die Seite der Freiheitsrechte
Und.
Auch sehr locker formatiert, muss man sag.
Ja, das ist sie, aber das ist gut so, sie sollen sich ja auch gut lesen, die sollen sich ja gut lesen. Wir haben auch
ein bisschen anonymisiert, ne? Also ist die Namen der Beschwerdeführer sind gestrichen, obwohl die meisten von denen eh öffentlich sind, aber wir haben die da rausgenommen, denn beim Google, der Beschwerdeführer ähm im sollen halt nicht als allererstes mal die Verfassungsbeschwerde auftauchen und wir haben auch eine Reihe von Daten geschlöscht
äh aus aktuellen Fällen, weil wir natürlich nicht wollen, dass die jetzt alle ähm mal so quasi aus Rache für diese Verfassungsbeschwerde mit einem Strafverfahren überzogen werden. Denn paar Sachen, die wir da schildern, erfüllen den Tatbestand. Sonst können wir ja nicht rügen, dass die Leute betroffen sind.
Na ja klar, stimmt,
So und jetzt aber man braucht dann hundertacht oder hundert über hundert Seiten, um das äh um das auszufüllen. Wir hatten hier auch in den letzten Sendungen, als wir euch vorgestellt haben, schon darüber gesprochen, das Konzept,
des strategischen Klagens, der Litigation, das heißt, ihr braucht es ja jetzt, wenn ich euer Konzept da richtig verstanden habe, braucht ihr die also Leute, die davon betroffen sind, da habt ihr ja offenbar.
Über zwölf gefunden, also es gibt da irgendwie noch dieses Pünktchen Pünktchen Pünktchen.
Nee, da stand in der Originalfassung der Hinweis
ähm dass das hinter, wir haben keine Schwerbeführer gestrichen, sondern da stand der Hinweis, dass die Beschwerdeführer teilweise Auskunftssperren haben im Melderegister, weil die eben natürlich bedroht werden, so jemand wie Hajo Seppelt oder so, der ständig irgendwelche russischen
Drogensünder outet, der möchte natürlich keinen Besuch kriegen von Igor und seinen Kumpels.
Stimmt, das war nämlich, das ist auch glaube ich derjenige, der den hab ich jetzt irgendwie viel äh äh in den Medien gesehen, in der Medienberichterstattung. Da bist du ja gar nicht so aufgetaucht, sondern der Anwalt, der das primär verfasst hatte wohl auch.
Ja die die Professorin, die das verfasst hat, Katharina Diladion Thai von der Humwold, die ist interviewt worden
relativ viel Christian Mier ist auch interviewt worden von Reporter ohne Grenzen. Aber um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen mit dem strategisch. Also wir haben am Anfang gesehen dass mit der Datenhildera ist ein Riesenproblem
Und dann haben wir ähm in der Tat versucht Menschen zu finden, die besonders gut nahelegen können, warum sie von dem Gesetz betroffen sind. Und dazu ähm liegt es natürlich nahe, mit Netzpolitik zusammenzuarbeiten, einfach weil das
vermutlich eine der Redaktionen ist in Deutschland, die am meisten, insbesondere elektronische Leaks bekommt. Ähm und weil die äh genau und deswegen haben wir die beiden, also André und Markus
Beschwerdeführer, weil die einfach sagen können, hey
wir arbeiten damit, das ist für uns ein Problem und die haben eben auch gerade diese Situation, dass bei vielen ihrer Leute nicht so ganz klar ist, ob die das jetzt berufsmäßig machen. Also ich mache berufsmäßig was ganz anderes, ich bin nicht berufsmäßig, Berater, Vernetzpolitik, das mache ich in meiner Freizeit, äh keine Ahnung, alle paar Wochen mal, ja?
Ähm und deswegen kann man eben am Beispiel von Netzpolitik und mir zum Beispiel sehr schön darlegen, wieso das ein Problem ist für die Pressefreiheit, wenn du als Journalist, als Journalistin nicht mehr mit externen Experten, wie eben zum Beispiel mit mir zusammenarbeiten,
Ähm das ist immer so die Idee, du hast ein rechtliches Problem und dann überlegst du dir, ähm,
Welch in welcher Konstellation kann man quasi so besonders gut ein Schlaglicht werfen, darauf warum das eigentlich ein Problem ist? Das ist ein Aspekt von strategischer Prozessführung quasi, die,
optimalen Beschwerdeführer zu finden. Und
Genau, das das haben wir dann und dann haben wir eben nicht nur die Netzpolitik Leute, sondern auch die klassischen Medien, sondern vom NDR, der mit den Panaba, Papers gearbeitet hat und eben Hajo Seppelt, aus der von den Russland Leaks
und den Matthias Spielkampf der ja vor kurzem diesen League aufgedeckt hat, ne? Mit den ähm mit der mit der Browser History, mit diesem, mit diesem Firefox
dass da irgendwie die gesamte äh Browser-History ähm hochlädt und nach Hause funkt und so. Also wir haben eine ganze Reihe, glaube ich, von aktuellen Beispielen. Wir haben auch einen einen Pantester, zum Beispiel, der Anne, der HRM Punkt K Punkt aus Karlsruhe,
Der hat sich inzwischen selbst geoutet, Mike Coukets, ist so ein IT-Sachverständiger, äh, Pantester
aus Karlsruhe, der auch ein sehr spannendes Blog übrigens betreibt mit mit,
Press Hadening Tipps unter anderem, ja, da konnte ich auch eine Menge lernen. Ähm also der ist auch mit dabei und der sagt.
Die Analyse gemacht von oder auch bei den Daten geholfen bei den Browser Plug-Ins-Analysen, ne? Ähm, wenn ich das.
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen, wo der konkret mitgearbeitet hat, aber auf jeden Fall ähm auf jeden Fall ist der Betroffene davon, weil der eben auch oft mitgelegten Daten
arbeiten muss. So. Und ähm ja und wir haben also wie gesagt versucht dieses Gesetz aus ganz verschiedenen Perspektiven zu beleuchten. Auch Journalisten, die in möglichst unterschiedlichen Kontexten arbeiten und zu den das Problem ist immer bei so einem bei so einer Verfassungsbeschwerde
dass Karlsruhe eine große Neigung hat, gerade wenn's gegen ein Gesetz direkt geht, ähm,
Gesetz so auszulegen, dass die Beschwerdeführer davon gerade nicht mehr betroffen sind
Das heißt also eines der Ziele war, wenn man wirklich an das Gesetz ran wollen, diesen Weg zu versperren, indem wir
Menschen mit so vielen verschiedenen Lebenssituationen haben, so vielen verschiedenen beruflichen Situationen, dass man das Gesetz eigentlich nicht mehr so auslegen kann, ähm dass äh dass keiner mehr betroffen ist
Das hoffen wir jedenfalls, dass uns das gelungen ist. Ähm sonst passiert nämlich häufig so, dass das Gesetz mal so verstanden wird mal so und ähm unterm Strich sei keiner mehr betroffen, aber wir hoffen, dass wir alle Hintertüren in unserer Verfassungsbeschwerde zugenagelt haben. Aber sicher ist man immer erst, wenn man den Beschluss bekommt.
Wie genau, da äh kommen euch jetzt, jetzt beschwert ihr euch da auf hundert, hundert Seiten, sagt hier so, dann kann der nicht mehr arbeiten und hier, das geht alles nicht mehr und äh und deswegen ist das nicht gut,
und schreib dir dann und jetzt bitte einmal ändern folgendermaßen
Oder wie, wie ist der Verlauf einer Verfassungsbeschwerde? Ähm, was wäre, was ist das gewünschte Ergebnis?
Also du das Schöne bei einer Verfassungsbeschwerde ist, du musst nicht sagen, wie es besser geht, sondern du musst nur sagen, das ist ein Problem. Und was Karlsruhe dann daraus macht, das entscheidet eben Karlsruhe,
Ähm unsere Hoffnung ist, das wäre so quasi der Hauptgewinn ähm dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht das Gesetz einfach für nicht erklärt,
Das wäre aus meiner Sicht die saubere Lösung, denn wenn.
Oder den Passus, äh.
Also das das Gesetz genau genommen diesen Paragraphen aus dem Strafgesetzbuch. Und es gibt da noch eine Begleitnorm aus der Strafprozessordnung, die zum Beispiel
erlaubt eben Unterlagen zu beschlagnahmen in Redaktion wegen Verdachts der Datenhelerei, ne? Das das finden wir ist unseren Aspekt des Gesetzes, der total zum Himmel stinkt. Also man sagt, es soll alles ja gar nicht zu tun haben mit äh mit der Pressefreiheit und wir wollen als Journalisten schützen,
dann ist das, wie soll ich sagen, nur noch so halb glaubhaft, wenn man zugleich sieht, ähm und das eben die Datenhederei auch dazu führt, dass Beschlagnahmeverbote in Redaktionen ausgehebelt werden. Ne,
im Paragraph siebenundneunzig, Absatz zwei der Strafprozessordnung kann man sich durchlesen in der Verfassungsbeschwerde. Ähm da wird's dann so richtig fischi. Also im Prinzip bin ich ja der Meinung,
glaube ich nicht, dass Heiko Maas jetzt bewusst die Pressefreiheit äh aufbohren wollte, sondern ich glaube, dass es also bei dem Referenten vermute ich inzwischen Vorsatz, der das verbrochen hat
bei dem einen Mitarbeiter im BMJ war das so eindeutig ist, aber ansonsten glaube ich, ist es eher so ein Fall von Schlamperei, dass einfach da hat das Vier-Augen-Prinzip nicht funktioniert. Da hat wirklich ein Typ, wenn man sich die Akten anguckt, ein Typ hat im Grunde das ganze Ministerium an der Nase rumgeführt,
auch ein tragischer Fall, ne? Also das sollte natürlich nicht passieren. Aber ähm aber ähm ja.
Da fehlt so ein bisschen Checksand-Balances.
Genau, der Checks and Balancer. Das äh kann man so sagen, ja genau. Also wir wir müssen nicht sagen, wir wollen was wir was wir besser machen wollen oder wie das,
besser hätte gemacht werden können. Wir sagen halt so geht's jedenfalls nicht. Bitte äh streichen diesen zweihundertzwei D und diesen diese Änderung in Paragraph siebenundneunzig Strafprozessordnung bitte auch und,
Wenn der wir schreiben aber schon an anderer Stelle, das muss man nicht, aber wir schreiben das rein, um um deutlich zu machen, wie schlampig das Gesetz eigentlich ist.
Wie man es hätte besser machen können. Man hätte ja, wenn es wirklich um Kreditkarten, Daten und um Logins geht, hätte man das ja einfach reinschreiben können. Man hätte ja sagen können, irgendwie Tatobjekte im Sinne von sind nur
Das ist ja nicht so schwer zu definier.
Also Userdaten et cetera, solche Bereiche halten.
Ich habe mal so in Formulierungsvorschlag gemacht, das steht in der Verfassungsbeschwerde auch drin
nach dem Motto Daten, ähm, die zur Legitimierung von Zahlungen verwendet werden, kommen insbesondere Kreditkartendaten und Daten, die zur Anwendung Anmeldung bei Telemediendiensten verwendet werden, insbesondere Login-Daten.
Ja oder ich meine da das Ganze ja nun in der in dem Paket Vorratsdatenspeicherung drin ist, hätte man es ja auch auch explizit auf genau diese Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdaten beziehen können. Das ist offensichtlich nicht erfolgt.
Das ist auch nicht passiert. Nein, es heißt einfach nur Daten und dann folgt ein Verweis auf Paragraph zwohundertzwo A des Strafgesetzbuchs und wenn man das nachliest, dann dann heißt es da Daten sind
Solche, die elektronisch, magnetisch oder sonst nicht unmittelbar wahrnehmbar gespeichert sind. Also das ist einfach mal alles. Diese müssen noch nicht ein Personenbezogen sein.
Jetzt könnte es ja äh sein, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass hätte jetzt so einen gewissen Erfolg, dass das dann mal wieder bedeutet, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, so wie sie beschlossen wurde, muss äh ohnehin nochmal neu aufgerollt werden,
in diesem Teil
was ist denn deine Sichtweise jetzt in Bezug auf die jüngste Entscheidung des EuGH nachdem er Schweden und Großbritannien da nochmal das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf die europäische Ebene geholt haben und im Prinzip der EuGH ja nochmal,
bestätigt hat, dass das so Manu gar nicht geht, hat das schon unmittelbare Auswirkungen auch auf die äh deutsche.
Vor Ortsdatenspeicherungssituation oder.
Das ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Also vielleicht nur um das, um da damit damit da jetzt kein Knoten im Kopf entsteht, also die Datenhinderer ist zwar beschlossen worden in dem fetten Paket zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber rechtlich
Kann das Bundesverfassungsgericht das völlig getrennt machen? Also in dem in den großen Klagen, die es gibt gegen die Vorratsseitenspeicherung spielt die Datenhederei auch allenfalls am Rande eine Rolle. Da hat sich bislang noch niemand Mühe gegeben und ähm
unser Verfahren, jetzt betrifft eben auch nur die Datenhelerei, das heißt also die anderen Probleme der Vorratsseitenspeicher haben wir hier nicht angesprochen, ne? Nur dass die Hörerinnen und Hörer da jetzt nicht durcheinander kommen. Ähm die große Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ist, denke ich schon betroffen durch die Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs. Das Problem ist nur, wie sich das jetzt ganz konkret auswirkt. Das ist äh extrem schwierig. Deswegen, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja
eigentlich nur am Maßstab der deutschen Grundrechte prüft eigentlich, das heißt also wenn Europa rechtliche Grundrechte
'ne Rolle spielen, dann ist das
Eigentlich nicht, was man vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht geltend machen kann, klingt erstmal komisch. Ähm ist aber so, ähm allenfalls kann und muss
Karlsruhe das deutsche Recht, auch das deutsche Verfassungsrecht quasi
auslegen, so wie auch die europäischen Grundrechte sind. Das klingt jetzt alles wahnsinnig schwierig und technisch bedeutet in der Praxis aber dass man sich in diesem Fall gut vorstellen könnte, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht tatsächlich mal den europäischen Gerichtshof fragt, was er denn hält.
Von von der Vorratsdatenspeichung in Deutschland, insbesondere. Ähm,
deutsche Grundgesetz möglicherweise so und so ausgelegt werden muss, ähm dass es die Vorratsseitenspeicherung nicht mehr zulässt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht da macht. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen Jurafu.
Aber du würdest jetzt nicht erwarten, dass das eine Folge von eurer Klage ist.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Wie gesagt, das, deswegen habe ich diesen diesen Knoten gerade versucht, aufzulösen. Das ist wirklich absolut sweiler. Das ist quasi
im selben Papier durch den Bundestag gewandert, ja? Glaube ich auch nicht zufällig, aber rechtlich sind es absolut zwei paar Schuhe,
Äh bei der Datenhehlerei ähm ist es halt einfach äh auf Linusfrage zurückzukommen, wie geht's weiter, ne? Ist jetzt so, wir haben eine Eingangsbestätigung bekommen von Karlsruhe, schon nach ein paar Tagen,
und die enthielt Leisa gleich die erste gute Nachricht. Ähm wenn man eine Strafrechtsnorm angreift, dann nimmt man normalerweise im zweiten Senat des Bundesverfassungsgerichts gibt ja zwei Senate und eigentlich landet man dann im Zweiten. Wir wollten
aber gern in den ersten Senat, weil der so 'ne Art Spezialzuständigkeit hat für die Pressefreiheit und wir finden eben Schwerp
dass dieser Diskussion sollte sein Pressefreiheit und nicht einfach nur irgendwie Strafrecht und ähm und das hat auch geklappt
Also wir sind mit der mit der Verfassungsbeschwerde im ersten Senat. Wir haben eins BVR Aktenzeichen, eins BVR achtundzwanzig einundzwanzig auf sechzehn,
und wir sehen das als vorsichtiges, positives Signal und erhoffen uns davon einfach, wie soll ich sagen, eine besonders wohlwollende Behandlung einfach, weil die im ersten Sinne sensibel sind, grundsätzlich für Themen der Pressefreiheit. Ähm
was da jetzt aber draus wird, weiß niemand. Der nächste positive Schritt wäre,
dass ähm die Bundesregierung und andere Behörden Gelegenheit zur Stellungnahme bekommen. Also jetzt ist es halt so, irgendein wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter oder eine Mitarbeiterin wird jetzt einen Vermerk schreiben zu unserer Verfassungsbeschwerde, so eine Art
Rechtsgutachten, was davon zu halten ist und einen Entscheidungsvorschlag machen und wenn wir Glück haben.
Dann wird der Entscheidungsvorschlag sein, wir sollten, also wir sollten oder also das Verfassungsgericht sollte der Bundesregierung uns zu ein paar anderen Behörden Gelegenheit zur Stellungnahme zu dem Gesetz äh geben
denn das wäre ein Zeichen, dass das Gericht die Verfassungsbeschwerde für möglicherweise begründet hält.
Ah okay, das heißt, wenn sie sagen würden, ach komm, aussichtslos.
Dann stellen sie es gar nicht erst zu.
Dann geht das, dann kriegst du irgendwann äh Verfahren eingestellt, äh haben wir keine Zeit für oder.
Nee, nee, du kriegst einen Beschluss, äh dass die,
Beschwerde nicht zur Entscheidung angenommen wird und dann kriegst du kriegst, wenn du Glück hast auch 'ne Begründung aber nicht immer. Mit dem Pech hast kriegst du einfach nur den Brief, dass das nicht zu entscheiden oder angenommen wird Punkt,
Das ist so das Worst Case Szenario, ähm weil du dann überhaupt nicht weißt, was los ist, ne. Das ist extrem unangenehm für Beschwerdeführer, aber leider häufig so, muss man offen sagen. Sehr häufig ist es so, äh dass kann alle möglichen Gründe haben, zum Beispiel bei schlicht und ergreifend, dass keine Mehrheit zustande kam.
Wie viele, äh, wie viele so verfassungsbeschwerden rasseln denn da eben ja rein. Wat.
Sechstausend etwa. Ja.
Aber die werden nicht alle angenommen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist genau das Ding, das die allermeisten werden nicht angenommen, also irgendwie ich weiß nicht mehr die ganz aktuellen Zahlen, etwa achtundneunzig Prozent werden nicht zur Entscheidung angenommen.
Wie sicher wart ihr euch, dass eure angenommen werden würde?
Du kannst dir nie sicher sein. Letztlich bist du natürlich auch in Karlsruhe ähm quasi in Gottes Hand, ja, wie auf hoher See so ungefähr, weil du es eins bist es einfach letztlich nicht klar. Du kannst auch Recht haben, aber einfach äh keine Mehrheit kriegen. Du brauchst ja
für jede Entscheidung, ähm die ein Gesetz aufhebt, brauchst du eine Senatsentscheidung und da müssen also fünf Richterinnen und Richter der Meinung sein, ja, dieses Gesetz wollen wir kipp
Und wenn so eine Mehrheit nicht zustande kommt, dann hast du halt, das ist halt keine Mehrheit und dann kriegst du der Nicht-Einnahme.
Ja und das ist aber steht bei euch sozusagen noch aus.
Ja, wir sind ganz am Anfang des Verfahrens und ähm klar, ich will das jetzt, ich will das nicht sagen, dass das nicht passieren kann
Es kann sein, dass auch diese Verfassungsbeschwerde nicht zur Entscheidung angenommen wird, aber das würde mich sehr wundern, weil es ja sehr, sehr viele Menschen gibt, äh wie ich finde, auch kluge Leute, die sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben.
Sag mal die sechstausend im Jahr. Ja. Das sind irgendwie hundertzwanzig die Woche sind irgendwie dreiundzwanzig am Werktag. Das heißt, die haben echt einen großen Briefkasten.
Mhm. Das heißt, sie haben echt einen großen Briefkasten. Die haben, ja, ja, klar. Äh ich habe das ja mal gemacht ein Jahr lang, als.
Ja, deswegen, deswegen weiß ich, dass äh du das gut beantworten kannst.
Ähm ja ja das äh das ist das ist,
Im Alltag auch eine Menge Akkordarbeit. Also du kriegst äh äh das ist ja, das läuft technisch so, die Verfassungsbeschwerden kommen rein, dann guckt sich die jemand an und sagt, welcher Senat ist zuständig? Dann gibt's in den Senaten
wiederum acht Richterinnen und Richter, da kriegt's dann einer auf den Tisch. Und normalerweise ist es so, dass die jeweils äh Asylrichterinnen und Richter jeweils vier wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter haben und einer von denen kriegt es dann wiederum auf den Tisch und
schreibt ein sogenanntes Votum oder ein Vermerk dazu, was im Wesentlichen so eine Rechtsgutachten ist und sehr, sehr viele sind,
ganz offensichtlicher Unsinn. Das muss man so offen sagen. Also ich habe in dem Jahr etwa achtzig votiert und die meisten Voten haben einen Vormittag gedauert oder vielleicht ein Tag.
Und das waren dann so ganz offensichtlich äh wesentlich zuständig, Dinger oder.
Nee, zuständig ist das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja so ziemlich für alles, ähm aber zum Beispiel keine Ahnung, Rechtsweg nicht erschöpft oder so. Ja, du kannst dich ja nicht einfach gleich gegen das Amtsgericht wenden, sondern du normalerweise, sondern du musst schon erstmal den normalen ordentlichen Rechtsweg ausschöpfen
oder Standardkonstellationen, wo einfach entschieden ist, dass das zwar nicht schön ist, aber kein Verfassungsverstoß. Also
keine Ahnung, äh um da mal ein Beispiel zu bilden, wenn irgendwie die Staatsanwaltschaft ein Verfahren,
einstellt, ähm nach Paragraph hundertdreiundfünfzig der Strafprozessordnung, wegen wegen weil die Schuld gering wäre, so wie das so schön heißt, dann ist das kein Freispru,
Manche Leute sagen aber, okay, das Verfahren ist eingestellt, ich werde nicht verurteilt, aber ich hätte eigentlich gerne einen Freispruch, weil ich war's doch nicht oder was ich gemacht habe, ist legal. Und erheben dann Verfassungsbeschwerde mit dem Ziel, äh diesen, diese Einstellung,
und ein richtiges Verfahren durchzuführen, das dann hoffentlich zu einem Freispruch führt. Das ist ein Klassiker, kommt ständig vor, ist aber kein Verfassungsverstoß. Sag er ist,
ewig schon entschieden, gehort trotzdem und du kannst aber gegen diesen Einstellungsbescheid äh der Staatsanwaltschaft nicht viel machen. Deswegen gibt's immer wieder Leute, die deswegen verfassungsbeschwerde erheben und ähm da ist aber halt nichts dran da.
Also viel fällt sozusagen unter Prior Art, so.
Ganz genau, du hast dann
oder du könntest fast auch sagen, Textbausteine, du hast also bestimmte Konstellationen ähm und gerade in Dezernaten, die für Spezialthemen zuständig sind, also damals war ich ja in dem Strafrechtsdezernat
bei Professor Hassamer und da hast du dann Konstellationen, die immer wieder vorkommt, ne? Da musst du jetzt auch nicht das Rad jedes Mal neu finden.
Und wie viele beschweren sich äh über die Bundesrepublik die Bundesrepublik Deutschland GmbH und die Chemtrails kommt sowas auch oder.
Das gab's auch damals schon. Beliebt sind immer die Verfassungsbeschwerden auf Butterbrotpapier mit null Komma fünffachen Zeilenabstand, mit alter Schreibmaschine, mit klemmenden Tasten getippt. Ja, ja, die gibt's natürlich auch.
Ja, ja, die gibt's natürlich auch und äh also das muss man sagen, das Gericht ist extrem professionell dabei, eigentlich kriegt die.
Jeder den gleichen Textbaustein zurück.
So ähnlich ähm also das Gericht trägt nicht nicht jeden Quatsch direkt als Verfassungsbeschwerde überhaupt ein. Also es gibt das sogenannte allgemeine Register, wenn,
offensichtlichster Unsinn ist,
wird das gar nicht erst als Verfassungsbeschwerde eingetragen, sondern nur in diesem allgemeinen Register erstmal geparkt und dann kriegen die Beschwerdeführer so ein ein Briefchen, wo im Prinzip drinsteht in freundlicheren Worten
das ist jetzt echt Quatsch. Ähm wir würden das jetzt mal zu den Akten legen. Es sei denn, sie bestehen darauf, dass wir das als Verfassungsbeschwerde behandeln und ähm da in diesem Filtersystem bleibt eine Menge hängen
Ja, die meisten Leute sagen dann, okay, wenn das so ist, na gut. Ähm aber manche bestehen natürlich auch drauf und dann kriegt man eben auch dieses Butterbrotpapier auf den Tisch und muss sich dann darüber ein paar Stunden Gedanken mach.
Kind, ne, ist ja immerhin, also ist ja äh so so sehr wir darüber jetzt gewitzelt haben natürlich doch auch richtig und gut und wichtig, dass man da ähm als Bürgergehör findet mit seinem, mit seinem Ansinnen, ne? Also.
Absolut, absolut. Absolut.
Hätte nun echt nicht gedacht, weil man gut jetzt aus unserer Blase dann doch sehr selten mal von einer Verfassungsbeschwerde hört,
Super, was heißt äh, aber jetzt zumindest nicht von sechstausend. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele kommen aus diesem Netzbereich. Okay, das wären jetzt dieses Jahr nochmal ein paar mehr durch euch, aber.
Ja, wir arbeiten dran, ne? Wir arbeiten dran.
Ja, also das ist schon eins der Ziele der GFF, dass wir halt schon versuchen, möglichst konsequent ähm problematische Gesetze auch anzugreifen, also auf Bundesebene hat das bislang
geklappt, die ganz populären oder ganz spektakulären Sachen sind ja auch bisher angegriffen worden, jedenfalls irgendwie,
aber ich sage mal gerade auf der Landesebene,
Bislang ja gar nicht. Also Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen Landesgesetze waren ja echte Ausnahmen und ähm gerade dort passieren auch richtige richtige Fehler teilweise. Also mal ein Beispiel zu bilden. Wir haben im Dezember eine Verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben gegen einen bestimmten Passus im neuen Transparenzgesetz Rheinland-Pfalz, der de fact
fragt den Staat verbietet.
Ne? Also das ist eine eine Klausel, die da steht dadurch nicht so wörtlich drin. Das steht drin, dass man eben Verfassungsbeschwerden äh Quatsch äh ähm DFG-Anfragen nur ähm quasi namentlich erheben kann
äh und fragt den Staat, wird nicht anerkannt, als äh als ein namentliches Einreichen von IFG-Anfragen. Das heißt also in Rheinland-Pfalz kannst du,
Nach der Intention des Gesetzes überfragt den Staat keine IFG Anfragen mehr stellen
und ähm da sagen wir, warum muss man denn eigentlich schon bei einer IFG-Anfrage überhaupt seinen Namen nennen? Wieso denn überhaupt? Gibt's überhaupt ein irgendeinen Grund dafür? Das ist ein
Eingriff in die informationelle Selbstbestimmung, dass man seinen Namen angeben muss bei der IFG-Anfrage. Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund dafür, wenn Kosten entstehen, dann kann man ja einfach äh an diese angegebene, frag den Staat E-Mail-Adresse ähm eine Bitte um Zahlung schicken und entweder geht die Kohle halt ein zu dem Aktenzeichen oder nicht.
Ja, dafür muss man den Namen nicht wissen. Also wenn nur ein bisschen kreativ ist, glaube ich, kann man IFG-Anfragen völlig anonym abwickeln und insofern ist das eine
unverhältnismäßige Einschränkungen der informationellen Selbstbestimmung, dass man eben IFG-Anfragen davon abhängig macht. Aber wie gesagt, ähm das und das geht's, da geht's um ein Landesgesetz, das wir wiederum in Karlsruhe angegriffen haben. Mal schauen.
Ihr seid jetzt ähm wenn ich das richtig sehe, habt ihr jetzt bisher fünf publizierte Fälle, in denen ihr vorgeht, also die Artikel zehn, BND Gesetz,
Transparenz klagen, speziell Rheinland-Pfalz da noch und jetzt die Datenniederei.
Genau bei Transparenz klagen ja nicht nur eine Klage ist, sondern das ist ja ein ganzes äh Projekt, wo wir ähm wo wir eine Menge Klagen finanzieren werden. Aber nicht für in Karlsruhe, sondern vor Verwaltungsgerichten.
Genau, darauf wollte ich nämlich gerade hinaus. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ihr jetzt nur auf Karlsruhe fokussiert seid. Das ist jetzt gerade mal äh ein Schwerpunkt einfach, weil die Sachlage so ist, aber grundsätzlich wollt ihr euch auf allen juristischen Ebenen austoben.
Grundsätzlich ja, wobei für uns immer im Vordergrund steht, wir wollen die Rechtslage allgemein verbessern,
sondern und nicht quasi Individualrechtsschutz. Es gibt ganz vielen Menschen, denen vermutlich auch in der Justiz Unrecht getan wird, weil irgendwas total schief läuft. Das passiert. Aber das ist nicht unser Thema.
Sondern wir wir sind jetzt nicht der, der Robin Hood, äh der irgendwie Fehler der Justiz korrigiert, sondern uns geht's darum, die Rechtslage generell für alle Menschen zu verbessern, deswegen bieten sich Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen Gesetze so an, weil Gesetze ja nun mal für alle gelten
wenn die ein Problem sind, die Gesetze kann man die Rechtslage für alle verbessern, wenn das Gesetz kippt oder verbessert
ne? Ähm bei den Transparenzklagen ist es so ein bisschen anders. Da geht's quasi um abgelehnte IFG-Anfragen, also keine Ahnung, ich möchte von irgendeinem Ministerium wissen, was die Party für den Minister gekostet hat und insbesondere, wer auf der Gästeliste stand
ja, gab's ja mal so eine Party für Merkel Party, ne.
Und ähm das möchte man von einem Ministerium wissen, das Ministerium möchte das aber vielleicht gar nicht mitteilen und lehnt diesen IFG-Antrag ab. Und dann, wenn das,
abgelehnt ist und auch das Widerspruchsverfahren foglos bleibt an, kommen Transparenzklagen ins Spiel ähm das ist das Pro
dass die GF zusammen mit der Open-Nollage Foundation hat, also mit frag den Start
Und da kann man sich bewerben, um eine sogenannte Transparenzpatenschaft, also man kann sagen, hey, meine IFG-Anfrage, die ist doch nicht nur für mich alleine spannend, sondern die ist generell spannend und da stellen sich auch interessante Rechtsfragen. Das Zweite ist auch wichtig, also
möglicherweise würden wir auch Sachen fördern, die von der Sache her interessant sind, alleine aber vor allem geht's uns um die Dinge, wo man auch eine Rechtsfrage klären kann.
Und ähm ja und da kann man sich dann eben nur eine Transparenzpatenschaft bewerben, da gibt's so ein kleines Team von Leuten, die bewerten diese äh diese Anträge und dann ähm
Wenn das, wenn er Sinn macht, dann fördern wir, dass also wir zahlen den Anwalt und die Gerichtskosten.
So und ihr könnt das alles machen, weil ihr auch gefördert werdet.
Jo, von zum Beispiel? Nein. Nein, aber Vielfalt. Nein, nicht, ich weiß gar nicht.
Trägt er den.
Viel für selber nicht. Nein, aber FIFA hat vor kurzem in seinem Blog
äh sehr nett aufgerufen dazu, die GF zu unterstützen. Klar, also wir sind äh wir sind natürlich darauf angewiesen, dass Leute unsere Spenden, beziehungsweise was wir noch lieber haben, dass Leute Fördermitglieder werden, weil ähm,
dass eine langfristige Planung erlaubt, ne? Wenn man einfach sagt, okay, da sagt jemand, ich finde das gut, ich zahle im Jahr einen Betrag X, damit ihr solche Klagen förder äh bezahlen könnt
dann können wir wiederum sagen, okay, das ermöglicht es uns zum Beispiel, Leute einzustellen. Also bislang machen wir das alles ehrenamtlich, deswegen können wir ein paar Sachen auf die Beine stellen, aber nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Ähm
und wir würden gerne ein bisschen professioneller werden. Also jetzt nicht irgendwie ein riesen Wasserkopf, aber so zwei, drei Leute würden mir schon gerne.
Das ist ja auch wirklich ein ein wichtiger Aspekt eigentlich bei allen Spenden äh finanzierten Gruppen, was alle sagen, ich kann das auch für die Mittebene sagen, so in dem Moment, also,
Spenden, Einmalzahlungen, alles super freut man sich drüber, aber man kann mit sowas ja nicht immer rechnen, aber wenn man halt sieht, aha, hier sind überschaubare Beträge, wo man davon ausgehen kann, dass Leute
jetzt nicht sofort hektisch, sofort wieder damit aufhören, weil's für sie, ne, erstmal zu einer schwierigen Situation kommen muss, bis man sowas dann äh komplett sein lässt oder
die nicht mehr mit einem Wahlstimmen in den Zielen natürlich. Ähm, von daher, das ist eigentlich die beste Form der Unterstützung.
Das kann ich nur unterschreiben, ja. Wir freuen uns über alles, aber Fördermitglieder sind einfach ein geben eine andere Planungssicherheit einfach, ne? Ja.
Ja, dann viel Erfolg.
Dankeschön.
Wir widmen uns jetzt dem Boulevard, oder? Oh, das ist auch schön.
Yeah. Obwohl das auch schön ist. Genau, jetzt müssen wir erstmal durchatmen. Jetzt wird's Juicy.
Oh Gott, das ging schnell. Es gab, es gab schon so eine wunder wunderbare Ansprache von Steven Kuhlbär in seinen Athletenights schon, wo er es wirklich geschafft hat in drei Minuten, so viele.
So viele Anspielungen unterzubringen. Oh, war ja, na ja gut.
Ich bin da, ich bedauere das ehrlich gesagt. Ähm also ähm wenn ich mir überlege, was wir eigentlich für schöne Themen haben, mit denen man sich auseinandersetzen könnte,
man hier einfach mal in Ruhe mit einem Juristen äh sich ein bisschen äh so hier Armshare Loyering betreiben kann und ein bisschen überlegt, so wie wie können, wie müssen Gesetz äh für unsere Gesellschaft gestaltet sein, welche Prob
haben wir um um irgendwie eine vernünftige Basis herzustellen.
Aber es ist der, es ist der sechzehnte Januar zwanzig äh siebzehn und für Lok Bundespolitik vielleicht die letzte Gelegenheit äh hier nochmal sozusagen vorher drüber gesprochen zu haben, weil in vier Tagen ist es ja dann soweit.
Tagen ist es soweit.
Dieser Mensch über den wir jetzt die ganze Zeit herumreden ist natürlich äh Mister Trump,
demnächst The Donald, der demnächst äh vereidigt wird, wie es aus, falls nicht noch irgendein Meteor den richtigen Weg findet. Ähm ja und äh,
Wir beziehen uns natürlich jetzt hier auf seine Pressekonferenz. Die erste, die ja glaube ich seit fast einem halben Jahr oder so gegeben hat.
Macht die ganze Zeit Pressekonferenz. So fingst du halt los, jetzt freut sich mal wieder eine Pressekonferenz, mache ich Martin Pressekonferenz, er macht die besten Pressekonferenz.
Alle seine Freunde.
Alle sind alle, alle sind immer da und vor allem er macht da tatsächlich die besten Pressekonferenzen. Die sind so gut, dass im Publikum die ganze Zeit applaudiert wird, so gut sind die, musst du mal überlegen.
So gut, so brilliant, das ist die nackte Begeisterung.
Das ist.
Davon sollte man, davon sollte man mal lernen. Warum haben wir hier eigentlich keine Claque hier im Studio.
Das ist äh ne, der nimmt die, also der reißt die Jubel per so richtig mit. Äh.
Kann man das denn nicht auch elektronisch irgendwie outsourcen? Habt ihr nicht so eine Lachmaschine? Das war da in den Neunzigern schon populär irgendwie. Knöpfchen drücken, Jubelstürme.
Lacher vom Band. Es ist.
Lacher vom Band. Das kannst du ja notfalls sogar mit YouTube einspielen. Tim, ich baue da auf dich.
Tim sucht hektisch das äh die die Maschine ab äh.
Wo ist denn hier frenetischer Applaus.
Ich habe sowas habe ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht. Das äh einzige, was ich so im Angebot hätte, wäre äh.
Es klingt aber auch.
Ja, wenn man Shoppacker an seiner Seite hat, dann kann einem eh nichts passieren. Kann man mitarbeiten.
Kann mit arbeiten. Kann man mit arbeiten? Sehr gut.
Also was waren die, was waren die Debatten der letzten Tage? Wir haben ja hier immer wieder besprochen, dass sie die Geheimdienste ähm.
Jetzt ja im die gesamte westliche Welt macht sich äh macht sich Sorgen, dass äh der Russe jetzt die Wahl heckt und so, das war bei uns in den letzten Wochen schon immer wieder Thema. Ähm.
Die Frage, die sich also gestellt hat, ist nachdem ja offenbar russische Hacker so viel äh über Hello Hillary Clinton gesammelt haben
Haben sie denn nicht vielleicht auch sich Donald Trump angeschaut? Und da gab es offenbar einen ehemaligen MI Six Agenten, der jetzt irgendwie so eher privat unterwegs ist, der da irgendwie mit der Aufgabe betraut war, doch mal zu gucken, was denn der
was denn der Russe so an Kompromat über Donald Trump angehäuft haben könnte.
Naja, mit ihm fing's ja nicht an, sondern es war ja so ein Unternehmen, was da beauftragt wurde von einem Republikaner, um irgendwie überhaupt erstmal über Trump was rauszubekommen. Also tatsächlich ging das von der republikanischen Seite aus und dann
hat er das aber wieder fallen gelassen, nachdem Trump dann wird die zum Kandidaten wurde und dann hat aber dieses Unternehmen
sozusagen sich einfach neue Auftraggeber gesucht, wenn man bei der demokratischen Partei angefragt.
Das ist auch so großartig.
Ob das äh ob die da nicht Interesse hätten und so weiter, das will sie wären auch schon so weit und ich glaube, die haben's dann auch irgendwann wieder sein gelassen und am Ende
Haben sie dann einfach mal selber weiter recherchiert oder haben das überhaupt erstmal gemacht? Und da kam dann halt unter anderem dieser ähm,
oder vielleicht auch nur der, das weiß man ja nicht, äh diese Person, dieser ehemalige MIMI Six Mitarbeiter des äh britischen Geheimdiensts MICX zum Tragen, der wohl ganz gute Kontakte nach Russland hat und da,
Dinge erfahren haben will.
Genau, der hat also dann ein, ein Report zusammen geschrieben und den dann eben, also ursprünglich, wie gesagt, von den Republikanern beauftragt, dann als der Trump tatsächlicher Dominie wurde von den Demokraten weiter beschäftigt.
Dann hat er irgendwie ein, ein, ein Memo verfasst, was dann ans FBI ging und ähm und der der rannte dann irgendwie rum und warnte irgendwie vor den verschiedenen Verstrickungen dieses Menschen und vor allem auch vor bestimmten ähm,
ja Druckmitteln, die
Russland eventuell gegen ihn haben könnte. Darunter eine relativ, also eine derartig absurde Geschichte, dass man sie fast schon wieder glauben könnte, dass er nämlich sich in,
Sankt Petersburg in das gleiche Hotelzimmer eingebucht habe, in dem äh Michelle und Barack Obama gewohnt haben.
Ja, das kann kein Zufall sein.
Das also das halte ich auch für für nachvollziehbar. Ähm.
Nicht nur das gleiche Hotel in das selbe Zimmer.
Dasselbe, es gibt auch in der Regel nur eine Präsidentensuite und die hatten sie wahrscheinlich, die hat er sich dann eben auch gebucht und dort soll er dann offenbar mit ein paar äh Gästen eine, eine äh Urinfeier,
veranstaltet haben,
irgendwie so so ab, also so irgendwie so komisch ist, äh dass man sich fragt, äh,
Also entweder dieser Mister Steel hat echt irgendwie einen an der Waffel oder die Russen haben den echt gut verarscht.
Wenn den Stil oder ins.
Gut seid, je nachdem wer seine Quelle ist, dass sie dem gesagt haben, nur was sagen wir dem denn jetzt mal? Ja, lass den mal
Auf jeden Fall dieser dieser Report, den er dann da formuliert hatte, der natürlich ohne jeglichen Beleg,
daher kommt, ne? Der einfach nur sagt, folgendes ist geschehen, das ist das Kompromat, was da angehäuft wurde und damit natürlich einer ähm,
In einer einem kritischen Blick in keiner Form standhält, ne? Der lag auch monatelang schon bei den verschiedenen Redaktionen rum,
keine keine Redaktion der USA hat sich getraut, dass überhaupt irgendwie in Erwägung zu ziehen, das Ding zu veröffentlichen, aber dann kam Busfit und dachte, ey.
Scheiß drauf.
Bringt Klicks und ähm haben dieses Ding dann eben veröffentlicht, äh was zu einer relativ lustigen äh also es gab eine Lust, einige lustige Mehmes, äh die daraus entstanden sind.
Bringt äh Klicks sicherlich, allerdings denke ich mal.
Bringt aber auch Ärger, ne?
Dürften die sich
durchaus auch bewusst gewesen sein, was sie dort für ein Risiko eingehen und äh haben's trotzdem gemacht, was sicherlich auch ein bisschen was darüber aussagt, wie angefressen die ganze äh Presse äh schon ist und vielleicht hast du dann eben in diesem Internetbereich ähm,
Leute, die sich mehr trauen. Das ist jetzt so,
wolkig formuliert, aber äh ich würde das jetzt einfach nur nicht jetzt nur unter diesem Aspekt mitbringen, Klicks äh summieren wollen.
Es hat net genau, es hat sowas so eine Veröffentlichung, hat den Effekt, dass äh,
vor allem natürlich, wenn du es jetzt rausdampfst, ne, dass dann entweder Leute vortreten können und sagen, ja, hier das stimmt. Oder sich eben Belege finden, dass es nicht stimmt. Ne und dann hat man's eben der der kritischen, dem kritischen Auge der Öffentlichkeit ähm zugeführ.
Ist aber nicht so der Klassiker, äh wie man so in der Presselandschaft meint, äh eigentlich traditionell zu arbeiten, weil ne, wenn man dann keine zweite Quelle hat, dann dann haut man das nicht raus. Das ist jetzt nochmal eine Unterdebatte, die braucht man jetzt, glaube ich, nicht zu führen.
Interessant ist, dass äh die die äh Pressekonferenz, die.
Donald Trump denn da abgehalten hat, natürlich sehr unter dem Stern äh dieser äh dieses Reporter stand und vielleicht können wir da mal kurz einen kleinen Ausschnitt einspielen.
Sicherlich.
Jetzt.
Und was dann natürlich geschah ist, die ganzen anderen anwesenden Journalisten äh im im äh haben dann in Anbetracht dieses Angriffs auf die auf die Presse und Meinungsfreiheit dieses Journalisten sofort
äh alle die gleiche Frage stellt und sich in Solidarität mit ihrem Kollegen verhalten nicht.
Nicht, genau. Das ist eigentlich Traurige, ne, an der Nummer.
Also da sitzt sie, die haben sich das komplette Ding da äh so in der Form gegeben, die haben sich das angeschaut. Der hat diesen CNN-Reporter an dieser Stelle das
äh das Wort verboten, weil er ihn vorher äh vorher sich,
Also er hatte vorher quasi gesagt, CNN hat diesen Report veröffentlicht und CNN ist deswegen schlecht. Das hat es CNN aber nicht getan. Und genau darauf auf diesen Vorwurf wollte der ähm der Journalist an dieser Stelle reagieren.
Hat dazu nicht die Gelegenheit bekommen und ähm seine Kollegen haben das offenbar auch für einen für ein akzeptables äh Vorgehen bei einer Pressekonferenz gehalten äh wie also wie wie es da
wie's da abgeht. Also ich kann nur sagen, dass das nach wie vor für einen äh in aller Ausprägung, für eine absoluten Alptraum halte, ja? Das auf dem Niveau mit derartigen äh äh Fak
mit derartigen Reports da irgendwie Politik gemacht wird, wie dieser Mensch darauf reagiert, wie die Journalisten, diese Debatte äh da führen, wie die Journalisten den gewähren lassen
dass er also äh sie angreift, äh dass er da eine eine Pressekonferenz mit mit Jublern macht, dass er äh Leuten das Wort verbietet oder die die Frage verbietet, das ist alles irgendwie so.
Ähm.
Ja, wie soll man das sagen? Ohne jetzt irgendwelche konservativen Begriffe zu verwenden, das ist wirklich ein ein Verfall an an irgendwie allen möglichen, denen ich da irgendwie sehe. Tim ähm,
City Stirn in Falten. Fandst du lustig oder.
Nö, ich fand das äh
natürlich überhaupt nicht lustig. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch nichts Neues, ne? Also man man hat jetzt nichts Neues äh gesehen, was nicht jetzt schon sich seit einem Jahr abzeichnet. Ich denke
das einzige, was jetzt hier vollkommen klar wird, ist, dass diese wage Hoffnung, er hätte ja die ganze Zeit da nur eine Rolle gespielt und wenn er dann erstmal in das schwere Amt kommt, dann würde sozusagen die Macht der Verantwortung und überhaupt
Rum und Ehre da irgendwie dann dann muss es doch mal reichen, wenn man ihn jetzt schon mal zum Präsidenten wählt, dann dann wird er vielleicht sein wahres, großes Herz zeigen
macht grad nicht so den Eindruck und ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt den, also ich wäre jetzt einerseits nicht überrascht, einiges von dem, was in diesem Dossier steht, auch einfach mal so stimmt,
also da wäre glaube ich auch niemand mehr so richtig überrascht. Äh ich frage mich allerdings, ob selbst, wenn's jetzt noch bestätigt werden würde, tatsächlich überhaupt noch in der Lage wäre, zu eskalieren. Weil ich meine, was da drin steht, ist ja im Prinzip, also,
Tatsächlich ist ja ist ja dieser dieser Hotelas
das ist so ein bisschen der Boulevardteil, ne? Aber was ja da eigentlich drinsteht ist, dass äh er halt äh mit seinen das Mitarbeiter von ihm halt Kontakte zu äh den Russen äh hatten im Vorfeld des Wahlkampfs
äh und ja, das ist ja dann sind wir irgendwie bei bei Landesverrat, ja, kommen hier mal ein paar T-Shirts äh schicken irgendwie,
ein Abgrund von Landesverrat, der dann äh sozusagen im Raum steht.
Das ist ja der eigentliche Skandal, ne? Nicht dieser Boulevardkram.
Genau und ich freue mich halt auch wirklich, es ist überhaupt Amerika noch in der Lage ähm sich aus diesem Schockzustand zu befreien, weil ich denke, was man bei diesem,
Journalisten jetzt auch merkt, ist, klar kann man den jetzt vorwerfen, dass er nicht alle geschlossen rausgelaufen sind, aber die haben ja auch alle noch so ein bisschen,
Die gehen ja irgendwie auch immer noch so ein bisschen davon aus, dass die Konventionen, die bisher alles getragen haben, auch noch eine Rolle spielen und sind jetzt auch noch nicht unbedingt bereit, äh die jetzt vor allem noch vor seiner Vereidigung komplett äh äh über Bord zu schmeißen, ja?
Gewisser Hinsicht auch ein Appell mit äh Leute, können wir jetzt mal äh hier zu unserem Modus Operandi äh zurückkehren, der jetzt uns seit ein paar hundert Jahren mehr oder weniger hält, ja
oder oder ist jetzt wirklich alles vorbei und von daher sind da schon noch ein paar Eskalationsstufen möglich.
Ja, die nächste Eskalation, also man muss natürlich sehen, diese Pressekonferenz war jetzt ja eben noch nicht im Briefing Room im weißen Haus, ne, sondern das war jetzt eben eine private Pressekonferenz, der Herr Trump.
Fälligerweise über entsprechende Immobilien verfügt und entsprechende repräsentative Räumlichkeiten und auch über acht äh schöne Fahnen. Der hat eben privat in seinem
gut in so einer guten Stube quasi zur Pressekonferenz geladen und ganz offensichtlich hatte er jetzt selbstverständlich erwartet, dass da so eine Art Hofberichterstattung stattfindet, ne? Deswegen.
Das war ja auch äh dieselbe Optik, wie dann die Pressekonferenzen auch später beim Präsidenten immer stattfindet. Also das war ja so vom ganzen Setup her schon.
Na, aber es war eben doch noch privat und er erwartet da ganz offensichtlich Hofberichterstattung und hinterher wurde auch gesagt
dass dieses CNN-Mitarbeiter nochmal einen Rüffel bekommen hat, also wenn sich das wiederholt, ne, dann würde er einfach gar nicht mal eingeladen und da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das so weiterläuft, ne? Also wir haben ja in Deutschland die sehr komfortable Situation
dass die Bundespressekonferenz gerade keine Bundesbehörde ist, sondern die Bundespressekonferenz ist ein privater Verein von Hauptstadtjournalisten. Das heißt
Regierungsvertreter sind zu Gast bei den Journalisten und nicht andersrum
Im weißen Haus ist es andersrum und hier bei Trump eben auch. Ne, da sind die Journalisten eingeladen beim Staat oder bei Donald Trump persönlich und
Die müssen eben auch nicht eigentlich wieder eingeladen werden, also wenn man House of Cards geguckt hat,
ne, da kommt es immer wieder mal vor, dass da Journalisten die Akkreditierung verlieren, das wird auch bewusst als Machtmittel eingesetzt. Nach dem Motto klar, kritische Fragen, aber es gibt Grenzen und wer diese die Grenzen überschreitet, der verliert eben so eine Akkreditierung und
Tschüss.
Ja, damit ist man dann im Grunde als Hauptstadtjournalist arbeitslos. Das kann in Deutschland in diesem Maße eigentlich nicht passieren, ähm aber ähm ja, ich glaube, die Presse in den Vereinigten Staaten muss sich da noch dran gewöhnen, aber ich denke.
Ähm so einen Verhaltenskodex, wie wenn hier Fragen abgeschnitten werden, dann müssen wir rausgehen
der müsste sich vielleicht etablieren, aber ich bin da etwas skeptisch. Nicht also letzten Endes, wenn der Wind dann jetzt nun mal eben aus Richtung Trump weht, dann habe ich so ein bisschen die Sorge, dass da doch auch viele sagen, na, was soll's, ne? Ich muss jetzt hier halt einfach sehen, wie es weitergeht. Die Berechnungen müssen bezahlt werden.
Das wird schon also genau deshalb muss man sowas eben dann als Journalisten in einem Zusammenhalt machen. Da müssen eben alle gehen und da muss auch ausnahmslos klar sein, dass dann da eben nur noch Breitbart vorne sitzt. So und dann.
Es bleibt im Raum. Breitbar.
Fließenden Übergang machen zum nächsten Thema der Fake News, denn ähm interessanterweise also die wahre Einflussnahme, die äh die man sich ja erwartet von den
vom von den Russen, ja? Die jetzt ja im ganzen Westen äh für für Unruhe sorgen werden, sind ja,
quasi Fake News. Das ist jetzt das Thema äh überall. Übrigens, so ein kleiner, also Donald Trump produziert ja mehr Fake News,
Als man in der Lage ist, äh zu widerlegen, ne? Also eine der einer der Sprüche war irgendwie zum Beispiel äh seine Inorgiration wird irgendwie so geil, dass man in ganz Washington kein Kleid mehr kaufen kann.
Das hat er jetzt zum Beispiel gesagt und dann.
Dann haben halt die, das stimmte natürlich nicht, ne, weil du die, weil weil diese ähm weil diese Kleider erstens nicht gekauft, sondern geliehen werden oder man die schon hat oder so. Also ist ja einfach Unsinn, ne,
Dann ist eben auch die Frage, setzen sich dann setzt sich dann jetzt eben die US-Hauptstadtpresse hin und interviewten Typen dem Kleiderladen gehört und sagt ja doch nee, hier ist eigentlich keiner reingekommen. Die gehen ja auch alle nicht hin, ne? Sie hat ja noch das, was der jetzt
tatsächlich Probleme äh Stars da für sein äh es gibt irgendwie eine lange Liste an Leute, die er angefragt.
Die alle nicht wollen.
Alle so irgendwie, ach nee, da habe ich gerade gar keine Zeit und irgendwie.
Zahnarzttermin.
Obamas gut bei Partys irgendwie mit, weiß nicht, hast du alle nicht gesehen, ne? Irgendwelche, wie heißt der Conny? Kein und und.
Nee, Canyon ist ja vielleicht der einzige, der da überhaupt noch auftritt bei Tramp. Das ist doch sein Busen.
Ach so, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich kenne die auch.
Äh du bist also du bist nicht äh.
Auf jeden Fall hat der hat äh Obama irgendwie ganz viele Stars und.
Ja, Obama hat die volle Unterstützung äh der, der doch recht liberal geprägt
Hollywood und und Musikkultur aber bei Trump ist halt nicht so, ne? Ich glaub die einzigen die sich bisher gemeldet haben, dass sie vielleicht singen würden oder so, die aber nur wenn ich irgendwie hier ein äh Lied gegen Sklaverei äh,
äh singen darf und so weiter, was natürlich jetzt für Trump auch nicht geht. Ne, das ist natürlich bemerkenswert, wird aber am Ende auch nichts ändern.
Worauf ich hinaus halte ist, der also so ein, wenn man jetzt dieses Beispiel nimmt,
Es gibt in Washington keine Kleider mehr, ne? Dann könntest du jetzt als Journalist hingen und sein des Unsinn, ne? Dann könntest einen Artikel drüber schreiben, dann musst du irgendwie einen Ein äh Journalistinnentag äh vergeuden, um äh um so eine unsinnige Lüge zu äh zu widerlegen
Und ähm dann ist es ist die Frage am Ende natürlich, ist es das wert, ne? Machst du das? Oder suchst du dir ähm vielleicht,
bedeutsamere Lügen,
die er wirklich zu einem Fundament seiner Politik erhebt, ja? Ähm! Zum Beispiel, dass Mexiko diese Mauer bezahlen würde oder so, ne? Oder äh wie machst du dieses Fact-Checking und gehst gegen einen Präsidenten vor? Der,
diese gesamte Fake News Geschichte im Prinzip ja äh gelernt hat, ne? Der erste ist, der das anwendet, der am am laufenden Band oder vielleicht auch nicht der Erste, aber der es sehr gut macht, der ähm.
Am laufenden Band lügt und.
In Deutschland führen wir ja auch gerade diese Debatte über Fake News und wir haben da auch schon hier öfter drüber gesprochen. Aber ich wollte mal so ein bisschen ähm beäugen, wie überhaupt Fake News,
werden,
wir jetzt gerade Debatten haben, es gibt im Prinzip zwei, zwei neue zwei neue Entwicklungen im Bereich der Fake News, einmal Patrick Sensburg, der sagt, ja, nee, da müssen wir eben äh müssen wir eben Netzsperren machen.
Ja, kennen wir schon von Terrorismus und äh dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs, da musst du jetzt auch nochmal bei den Fakenes, wenn Thema lange genug in den Medien ist, muss der Netzsperren äh fordern,
Und das andere ist, dass der von uns auch vor einigen Wochen schon behandelte äh Schritt von Facebook quasi Fact-Checking,
in die Plattform zu integrieren. Äh jetzt in Deutschland ähm mit dem Recherchebüro Korrektiv,
gemeinsam durchgeführt werden soll und spätestens äh da finde ich es interessant sich nochmal mit diesem Phänomen auseinanderzusetzen, weil.
So dieses prominente Beispiel Renate Künast hat das und das gesagt und dann weiß man, das ist falsch und dann gibt's auch nichts daran zu rütteln. Das ist ja ein bisschen das ist ja eines der eines der wenigen prominenten Beispiele,
immer wieder zitiert werden während die ganze Zeit im im Netz glaube ich dieses Fake News Konzept ein ganz anderes ist, nämlich ähm,
äh der Inhalte, wo Fake News eher so im Nebensatz stehen,
wo so eine eine falsche Andeutung gemacht wird, wo du jetzt gar nicht unbedingt sagen kannst, okay, nee, das ist jetzt wirklich eine Lüge, sondern das ist einfach schon so eine, das setzt fünf Lügen voraus,
Das, was da gesagt wird. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass auch der Kampf gegen gegen Fake News, wie auch immer er geführt werden soll. Äh im Moment noch vollständig falsch konzipiert ist.
Wie wäre denn deiner Meinung nach richtig konzipiert.
Das kommt danach. Erstmal müssen wir jetzt hier sagen, was alles falsch ist.
Na gut, aber ich meine äh
Jetzt müsste man ja dann festhalten, äh ist denn das jetzt ein falscher Schritt von Facebook als Plattform sich äh so aufzustellen mit äh unabhängigen schwierigen Worten im Zusammenhang äh Organisationen
ähm hier überhaupt erstmal so ein Bewertungssystem einzuführen. Worauf es ja im Prinzip hinausläuft, ne? Man kann halt irgendwas melden, man hat
quasi verlässliche Quellen oder vermeintlich verlässliche Quellen, also wir ist hier korrektiv, keine schlechte Arbeit unterstellen, nur das überhaupt nicht, nur äh selbstverständlich wird natürlich dann auch die Glaubwürdigkeit dieser Gruppen genauso angezweifelt werden,
und da werden wir dann auch entsprechende Gegenbewegungen sehen, von daher ist es halt fraglich, ob das dann am Ende auch wirklich genau diese Wirkung hat, die man sich davon verspricht.
Und ähm trotz alledem nichts tun, ist jetzt vielleicht auch keine äh Option. Frage ist natürlich, was ist das äh beste Mittel?
Also ich ich würde einfach nochmal so einen ganz kleinen Input geben äh aus der Perspektive unseres Grundgesetzes, denn ähm,
Fake News sind ja wahnsinnig schwer abzugrenzen von Meinungsäußerungen und ich glaube, dass ähm das ist ganz, ganz, ganz wenig Spielraum gibt
echte Meinungsäußerung schlicht zu verbieten. Ne, also wenn wenn Sensburg sich hinstellt und sagt, wir müssen Fake News einfach verbieten, dann funktioniert das eigentlich nur in dem ganz, ganz, ganz engen Bereich, wo jemand sagt, zwei und zwei ist fünf.
Ne, also Dinge, die quasi Naturwissenschaftlich falsch sind, wo man sagen kann, das ist jetzt einfach eine falsche Tatsachenbehauptung und die hat auch überhaupt keine Meinungskomponente. Das ist einfach nur falsch. Da könnte man möglicherweise drüber nachdenken, ob man das in irgendeiner Art und Weise reguliert. Das ist dann natürlich
Technisch wahnsinnig schwierig umzusetzen, aber da hätte man rechtlich vermutlich einen Spielraum, weil reine falsche Tatsachenbehauptung ähm eben grundsätzlich keinen verfassungsrechtlichen Schutz genießen, wenn man halt einfach sagt
Eine Lüge trägt nichts zum Diskurs bei. Aber sobald du irgendwie deinem Ganzen so ein, so ein, so ein Aspekt des Meinens
hinzufügst, sondern das ist ja bei fast allen Artikeln so, auch bei den sogenannten Fake-News-Artikeln, kannst du das nicht mehr so einfach verbieten, dann könntest du also nur hingehen und sagen, diese drei Halbsätze, die müssen jetzt quasi geblenkt werden und da möchte ich mal wissen, wie das
praktisch funktionieren soll. Ich glaube, der Sensburg-Vorschlag ist also jenseits,
politischer Überlegung, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist, ne? Fake News einfach nur so zu sperren, ob das nicht eigentlich eher so eine Art Opfer der Mentalität äh befeuert, ne, nach dem Motto, ja, hier werden wir zensiert und so. Ähm jenseits dieser ganzen praktischen Fragen und politischen
Klugheitsfragen ist es einfach auch rechtlich kaum möglich, das einfach mal so abzuschalten und
Was aber rechtlich eben möglich ist, denke ich, das ist schon sehr weitgehend passiert. Also bald es um Personen geht, gibt's reihenweise Straftatbestände, ne? Beleidigungen, üble Nachrede, ähm.
Und da kann man jetzt schon Strafanzeigen stellen, da kann man auch jetzt schon sich persönlichkeitsrechtlich dagegen wehren, da kann man keine Ahnung, Unterlassungsverfügung erwirken und so. Also der rechtliche Rahmen Fürke News, der ist einfach schon,
Ich würde mal sagen, nahezu ausgeschöpft, da geht einfach nicht mehr viel. Insofern ähm geht diese Debatte völlig am Problem vorbei, ne, zu sagen, wir müssen brauchen da neue Gesetze. Wenn überhaupt geht es darum, die Gesetze, die wir haben, effektiv umzusetzen und da denke ich mal, ist Facebook einfach,
einer der größten Sünder, die wir haben muss momentan, ne, weil die eben nicht zusammenarbeiten und zwar weder mit der Ziviljust
Stichwort Landgericht unterlässt eine unter Belassungsverfügung, noch mit der Strafjustiz, außer wenn's jetzt wirklich um Schwerstkriminalität geht und ich glaube, da müsste, wenn wir die Politik was tun will, sollte sie da ansetzen
dass also Plattformen mitspielen.
Jetzt würde ich okay, mitfinden kann man sagen, jetzt würde ich mich nur fragen bei der.
Selbst wenn es jetzt, wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, es gibt diese juristischen Mittel,
und jetzt haben wir schon gesehen in welchem eingeschränkten Rahmen, die sich bewegen können und dann hast du gehen wir aber mal davon aus, die kämen jetzt zum Einsatz. Bei der Schnelllebigkeit,
Sozialer Netzwerke. Kannst du doch mit den juristischen Mühlen äh dir zurecht,
Und aus gutem Grunde langsam malen, ne? Das wäre das äh denke ich, ist nicht nur, äh, dass wir hier nicht irgendwie die ganze Zeit Schnellverurteilung und so weiter haben, sondern Saffalte vernünftig geprüft werden. Ist ja ein Vorteil.
Äh unseres juristischen Systems. Deswegen glaube ich, dass du, selbst wenn da jetzt irgendwie juristische Mittel geschaffen werden und so, du nicht vernünftig gegen dieses Phänomen vorgehen kannst, weil es eben erstens, wie du schon sagst, sich in den Nebensätzen verbirgt,
ähm schwer zu fassen ist und drittens, selbst wenn du dann irgendwie daraus einen Fall machen würdest, du Wochen oder Monate damit beschäftigt bist, wä.
Alle drei Minuten eine neue Sau durchs Dorf getreibt.
Also im Prinzip im Prinzip stimmt das, aber ich glaube, er muss ein ganz kleines bisschen genauer hingucken bei den
Bei den äh bei den persönlichkeitsrechtlichen Verfahren Stichwort. Ich gehe jetzt zur Pressekammer und ich lasse dem Linus Neumann verbieten über mich zu sagen, komm mal das. Ähm bei diesem Verfahren geht das sehr schnell. Da reden wir von Stunden bis Tagen
Also das geht wirklich extrem fix, ähm dass du hier zum berühmt berüchtigten Landgericht Hamburg gehst und Unterlassungsverfügungen gegeben ist, da reden wir von Stunden bis Tagen. Das.
Gegen mich, nicht gegen das, dass alle, dass dann alle Leute, also diese, diese Fängnis werden ja auch tradiert, ne? Es sind nicht alle, es linken ja nicht alle auf eine Stelle, sondern,
schreiben dann wieder was wie ich letztens gehört habe, hat eine was weiß ich also die werden ja dann auch wieder neu erzählt als als Frau Klo.
Klar, das ist natürlich ein Problem, die werden.
Weitergetragen.
Ja. Aber gut, ich meine, eine önome das kurz klarzukriegen, also grundsätzlich mal geht das schnell, was lange dauert, sind Strafverfahren, aber wenn du jetzt bestimmte Typen hast oder bestimmte Journalisten, bestimmte Autoren, die immer wieder Fakenews verbreiten und die haben dann immer wieder Strafverfahren am Hals.
Könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das mittelfristig funktioniert. Also
In dem Bereich. Es dauert lange, aber es bedeutet, es nimmt eben doch auch Akteure irgendwann mal aus dem Spiel. Also wenn dies total übertreiben. Das geht natürlich nicht beim Ehren. Ne, es dauert, aber ähm ich denke eine gewisse abschreckende Wirkung hat es auch, aber beide,
Wege laufen momentan weitgehend ins Leere, weil Facebook nicht mitspielt
Wenn du jetzt ein ein Beschluss bei Gericht beantragen willst, musst du ja sagen, wo der hinterher zugestellt werden soll. Gegen wen der eigentlich gelten soll. Und Facebook, Irland ist mal kein tauglicher Adressat.
Oder Facebook Kalifornien,
Das heißt also, was man als allererstes mal bräuchte, wäre Schiene greifen eine Adresse von Facebook in Deutschland, wo ein Landgericht XY überhaupt eine Verfügung zustellen kann, wird untersagt, die Behauptung so und so weiter zu verbreiten.
Und das könnte dann nämlich durchaus, wenn sich gegen Facebook richtet und nicht gegen den einzelnen Autor könnte es ja durchaus so lauten, zu sagen, es wird der Plattform Facebook verboten, die Behauptung so und so weiter zu verbreiten,
Und dann wird's nämlich spannend. Aber das funktioniert technisch nicht. Rechtlich ist das nicht das Problem, das funktioniert technisch nicht, weil wir das, weil man einfach Facebook in Deutschland nichts zustellen kann. Strafverfahren
selbes Problem, wenn auch in anderem Gewande, wenn ich jetzt eine Anzeige stelle gegen irgendeinen Facebooknutzer und sage, der hat mich da aber beleidigt oder der hat zum Mord gegen mich aufgerufen oder so. Dann sagt Facebook ist sehr schön, aber ist nicht unser Problem.
Ist jetzt etwas polymisierend formuliert, aber das gibt's reihenweise, Beispiele. Christopher Lauer hat das vor ein paar Monaten erlebt, dass er mit
mit Straftaten bedroht wurde und Facebook hat schlicht und ergreifend die Sachen nicht rausgerückt. Das haben sie dann auf anderem Wege, weil der mit Plannamen gearbeitet hat und so ist es dann noch zu einer Verurteilung gekommen, aber Facebook hat überhaupt nicht mitgespielt, obwohl er das als
Politiker eskaliert hatte, irgendwie über die Facebook Deutschland Pressefrau, die Frau Kirschsieper da, ähm also hat das wirklich versucht, mit allen Mitteln, auch so außerhalb des normalen Weges und Facebook hat einfach nicht kooperiert, die IPs nicht rausgerückt,
die Anmeldedaten und so. Und deswegen denke ich ähm wenn man politisch aktiv wird, ist einer der ganz wesentlichen äh Forderungen
eine Kontaktstelle für zum Beispiel Facebook, aber das müsste genauso, denke ich, gelten für andere, jedenfalls relevante, soziale Netzwerke, wie zum Beispiel Twitter
Eine Kontaktstelle, wo überhaupt Beschlüsse zugestellt werden können und wo auch Ermittlungsbehörden bestimmte Daten abrufen können, denn ähm
Ich denke mal, es ist immer noch besser, wir bekommen eine Form von justizieller
In Anführungsstrichen Kontrolle, ja, also in der rechtsstaatlichen Kontrolle von Inhalten, als wenn äh als wenn zum Beispiel einfach direkt die Politik durchregiert.
Ne, also wir haben da um das auf den Punkt zu bringen. Wir haben ein Rechtsdurchsetzungsproblem, weil die Plattform in Deutschland keine Ansprechstelle haben, keine Ahnung, keine Anlaufstelle. Deswegen die Forderung, eine Kontaktstelle von Facebook einzurichten,
und die ist ja interessanterweise im politischen Spektrum extrem breit. Der Hamburger Justizsenator fordert das,
aber es fordert zum Beispiel auch Thomas Jazzombek von der CDU der Netzpolitiker, also das ist eigentlich 'ne Forderung, die sehr, sehr breit im politischen Feld vertreten wird. Ich würd mir wünschen, dass Heiko Maas da
mal versucht einen konkreten Vorschlag zu machen, wie man Facebook dazu bekommt, eine solche Kontaktstelle einzuricht,
Zum, ich sage jetzt mal Facebook, ne, aber gemeint sind soziale Netzwerke mit einer gewissen Relevanz. Welche das dann sind, da muss man sich eine Definition überlegen.
Das ist auch die Frage, wer kann sozusagen jetzt verpflichtet werden? Bei Facebook ist es irgendwie offensichtlich, dadurch, dass einfach so viele Leute sind, ne? Aber heißt das, dass man dann sozusagen muss der Netzpolitikorg auch irgendwann äh mit.
Müssen sie heute schon, Netzpolitik hat ja eine Adresse. Schönerweise Allee sechs bis sieben in Berlin kannst du einen bürgerbekannten Brief hinschicken.
Netzpolitik speichert halt nicht, ne? Aber im Zweifel könnten die schon auch die Adresse äh
angeben, von der ein Kommentar gepostet wurde. Selbstverständlich, es gibt auch einen Anspruch da drauf. Also wenn eine Ermittlungsbehörde wissen möchte, wer den Kommentar so und so gepostet hat,
muss Netzpolitik denn rausrücken, steht in Paragraph fünfzehn des TD Mediengesetzes. Wir brauchen da keine neuen Gesetze. Was wir da brauchen ist eine Durchsetzung gegenüber nicht deutschen Plattformen.
Netzpolitik hat äh wird es äh im Zweifel nicht loggen, aber jedenfalls hoffe ich das, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, wie das so läuft
aber grundsätzlich mal gibt es durchaus einen Anspruch von Ermittlungsbehörden. Wahrscheinlich stellen nur nicht so häufig äh Leute Strafanzeigen wegen Kommentaren bei Netzpolitik.
Ich würde mich jetzt äh ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass selbst wenn es da einen Recht Rechtweg gebe, wie er dieses Problem bis zur Bundestagswahl nicht im Griff hätten.
Da bin ich bei dir ja, denn wir brauchen natürlich weitere Elemente, ne.
Und da finde ich tatsächlich ähm diese also.
Ich sag das immer so ein bisschen, wir im Prinzip diese Fake News fallen ja auf einen fruchtbaren Boden. Und der ist auf einmal irgendwo hergekommen. Da da spielt die Rolle, also der spielt Facebook auf jeden Fall eine Rolle,
durch dieses, ne, Like und Share und und hier jetzt kriegst du irgendwie nur noch die Sachen gezeigt, die dir gefallen und dann gibt's irgendwie so eine Filterbabbe. Dann bilden sich Öffentlichkeiten quasi ohne Korrektiv,
von von Like Mindet in the Vitrols, die irgendwie alle sagen, äh,
was weiß ich, wer jetzt wieder gerade mal ähm ein Volksverräter ist oder was auch immer. Und da ist für Facebook natürlich so ein, so ein verstärkender
selbst wie nennt man das? So ein Selbstfall, so ein Teufelskreis eigentlich, der den Leuten da gegeben wird. Ähm.
Zweitens gibt es offenbar Leute, die erstens solche Sachen hören wollen und äh auch nicht in der Lage sind ähm,
'ne allgemeine kritische Infragestellung des Gelesenen aufzubringen
die wir eigentlich so ein bisschen immer voraussetzen, ne, dass wir, dass wir, dass wir Leute haben, die das, was sie lesen, vielleicht auch nochmal so einen groben Lachtest unterziehen, ob das irgendwie äh ob das überhaupt sein könnte,
Und wer ihnen das eigentlich gerade erzählt, das das ist irgendwie den Leuten so ein bisschen abhanden gekommen und deswegen finde ich die den Grundgedanken, den Facebook da verfolgt, zu sagen, erstens, es sind zwei, in den meisten Fällen ist das nun mal Meinungsfreiheit, das,
passiert. Äh insbesondere bei der dann doch etwas äh ähm,
etwas großzügigere, großzügigeren Auslegung von Meinungsfreiheit, die in USA herrscht. Ähm.
Dann aber zu sagen, na ja, wenn da aber wenn der Fakt, wenn da Lügen verbreitet werden,
ähm dann wollen wir den Leuten wenigstens helfen, die zu erkennen, wenn sie schon selber nicht checken,
ja? Und da geht's ja eben um die Idee, dass es einen Meldebutton geben wird. Im Moment kann man Sachen melden für für auch irgendwie für Spam oder für für Hate Speech oder sowas, ne? Und jetzt gibt's halt irgendwie auch den den Meldeb
Fake News. Und den kann man oder wird es dann halt äh geben und wenn denen genug Leute gedrückt haben, so jetzt das Verfahren
dann landet die Geschichte bei Factcheckern und
äh zur allgemeinen äh Überraschung äh wurde dann jetzt am Wochenende bekanntgegeben, dass das das Recherche-Korrektiv, äh das Recherchebüro korrektiv.
Zunächst
kostenlos übernehmen wird. Dieses zu unternehmen für Facebook. Er ist auch irgendwie geil äh ne, als als als gemeinnützige äh
Als gemeinnütziges Recherchekollektiv dann ausgerechnet für so einen Milliardenunternehmen äh äh ehrenamtliche Arbeit zu leisten. Ähm.
Irgendwie ist, irgendwie ist es skurril, ne.
Ist ein bisschen skurril.
Fast noch skurriler, wenn sie dafür bezahlt werden würden.
Es wäre auskuriert, wenn sie dafür bezahlt werden, wenn irgendeiner wird's halt machen müssen, ne? Und es wird dann eben so sein, dass sie quasi, also der der Prozess soll irgendwie quasi mehrstufig sein, äh,
Nutzer pflegen eine Behauptung als Fake News ähm dann landet sie bei Korrektiv, die sagen, ja, stimmt, das ist
es ist nicht wahr, was da steht und dann soll eben in Zukunft wird dann quasi der Nutzer wird gewarnt, ja? Also das geht dann erstens die die Nutzer, die das rezipieren, kriegen dann was weiß ich einen gelben Rand. Hör mal, hier äh das ist eine umstrittene Äußerung
Und ähm wir haben oder sie ist sogar nachweislich falsch ähm und wenn man die dann weiterverbreiten möchte, dann wird's aus einem Klick werden zwei,
Und äh dann wird wohl auch noch
in Erwägung gezogen, tatsächlich eine algorithmische Benachteiligung ähm bei dem Einblenden einzuführen. Da wir ja wissen, dass äh Facebook äh bei weitem nicht alle Beiträge
ähm anzeigt, die man zu denen man sich subskribiert hat, wo man eigentlich ganz klar das Interesse bekundet hat. Ich möchte alles von dieser Person oder von
Account haben. Hör auf Facebook, nein, machen wir nicht. Wir nehmen dir eins einfach mal einiges wieder weg und dann müssen die Leute dafür bezahlen, dass wir es doch doch zeigen oder was.
Das übrigens erleben wir ja gerade auch sehr deutlich bei der GFF, ne? Ich habe das, wir haben also gewisse ähm gewisse Posts mal geboostet, da haben wir so ein bisschen ausprobiert. Äh und wenn man das dann aber nicht mehr tut, ne, dann dann,
passt Facebook einem so einen richtigen Cold Turkey, ist kein Witz. Also da merkst du mit einmal, dass du überhaupt keine Reichweite mehr hast. Also ich habe das natürlich kann das nicht statistisch belegen.
Weil's wenn man keine Kohle drauf wirft.
Ja, als
Also wir hatten, wir haben am Anfang einfach mal unser Facebook-Profil eingerichtet. Ähm ist ja auch nee, nicht ganz, wie soll ich sagen, nicht ganz unheikel, für eine Organisation, die sich grundsätzlich ja auch dem Datenschutz verschrieben hat, auf der anderen Seite, man muss die Menschen fürchtlich auch da abholen, wo sie sind. Gut, brauchen wir nicht ausdiskutieren, jedenfalls haben wir eine Facebook-Seite, die wir im Wesentlichen immer mit unserem Twitter-Fee
bielen.
Auch diskutieren, wir haben diese Debatte ja auch schon gehabt.
Äh die wir im Wesentlichen mit unserem Face äh Twitter Feed äh Co bespielen und wir haben am Anfang gesehen, das läuft ziemlich gut. Also man hatte dann eine Quote von irgendwie, man sieht ja auf Facebook, wie viele Leute man erreicht hat, ne? Und die Quote war.
Daneben steht immer ich drücke hier.
Viele könnten es sein.
Genauso viele können es sein, ne? Ja genau, da da tanzt dann auch. Na gut und äh am Anfang war war die Quote also relativ nah an der Zahl unserer unserer Likes. Also da hatten wir keine Ahnung fünfhundert Likes und wir sagen aber.
Schon so absurd ist, ne? Ich meine, da haben dann schon Leute explizit mal einen Button geklickt mit da interessiert mich, sage ich mal, ja. Äh aber dann kriegst du halt die Information halt trotzdem nur zufällig.
Das ist doch skurril.
Sozial, das ist einfach ein As.
Aber gut, immerhin.
Asoziales Netz.
Also da bin ich ganz bei Andi Müller Magun, der seit Jahren sagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum diese Dinger soziales Netzwerk heißen, die sind doch asozial. Das ist wirklich einfach, dass er.
Ist ja da gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, was ich noch sagen wollte, ist die Zahlen waren, die Zahlen waren gut. Ja, die Zahlen von Impressions waren gut und dann haben wir mal so ein bisschen geboostet und seitdem sind wir im Cold Turkey. Jetzt haben wir nur noch so zwanzig Prozent der Leute, die wir, die uns liken, kriegen das angezeigt. Ich weiß nicht, ob,
ob da Facebook irgendwie so einen fiesen Algorithmus hat, der der einen dann eben auf den kalten Entzug setzt, wenn man mal geboostet hat, damit man immer wieder boostet, aber für mich sieht es wahnsinnig so aus, als wenn sie eine erst anfüttern und dann kriegst du so einen Buß und dann,
Und wenn man sagen muss unser unsere Boosts haben fand ich auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut funktioniert. Wir hatten dann mich mit einmal die AfDler in den Kommentaren, ne? Nach dem Motto wirklich so ohne Witz, Leute, die dann schreiben, ging irgendwie ums BND-Gesetz, ich habe nichts zu verbergen oder
Ja, das ist wir sind doch eh von von Tel Aviv gesteuert und bla, bla, bla, so richtigen Ulmsinnen, das heißt, du musst das dann total
total streng moderieren, du musst den ganzen Quatsch rauslöschen, die Leute benden und so, also Boost auf Facebook für eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation ist glaube ich auch so mittelmittelinteressant nur.
Das heißt, das ist dann sozusagen eigentlich kontraproduktiv, dann lieber in der.
Frag mich, wer kriegt das angezeigt?
Lieber in der Blase bleiben.
Ja und ich hatte vor allem natürlich ein, ich hätte natürlich die Audience, wie das so schön heißt. Du kannst ja bei so einem Booster auf Facebook, kannst ja festlegen, wer das heute angezeigt kriegen. Ich hatte halt ähm angezeigt, Leute, ähm von denen ich annehme, dass die im Prinzip das sinnvoll finden. Leute, die mussten geliked haben. Ich glaube, die,
P, die Grünen oder die SPD mussten die Leute geliked haben und äh oder alternativ mussten sie Netzpolitik geliked haben oder irgendwie noch so ein, zwei und Amnesty oder so. Ich hatte.
Und welcher Hautfarbe hast du angegeben? Man kann dir die Hautfarbe aussuchen.
Nicht wirklich, kann man das auch? Das hat,
echt jetzt? Nee, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht. Ich hatte so nach politischen Interessen und äh und ich dachte, wenn man das so ein bisschen so äh so definiert, dann kriegst du halt Leute, ne, wo die dann auch deinen Ideen so halbwegs offen gegenüber stehen, stattdessen kriegst du da die Hardcore.
Ist die Feindbeobach.
Die Spinner da irgendwie. Na ja, wir haben.
Super und jetzt kommen sie mal wieder an äh Watscheln, halten dir deine alten Urlaubsfotos. Hier vor drei Jahren, wie schön war's damals, als noch geboostet wurdest.
Ja oder Friendship ist das schönste auf dem auf einem äh auf der Erde irgendwie und du bist jetzt seit drei Jahren mit dem Linus befreundet, möchtest du das nicht auf Facebook feiern?
Möchtest du dich nicht heiraten?
Reichweite muss sich wieder lohn.
Knau so unge.
Okay, also die die Fake News, die Fake News. Ähm dann kommen wir ähm ja, das ist vielleicht auch so äh Frage, Fake News oder nicht Fake News. Interessantes Thema, ähm das uns in der letzten Woche beschäftigt hat, hat WhatsApp eine Backdorf oder nicht?
Geil, das war, das war wirklich ein sehr schönes Beispiel für ein Spin, der völlig in die Irre gelaufen ist, oder?
Ich war also ich versuch's mal technisch,
grob zusammenzufassen. Wir haben ja schon eine etwas lange Sendung, aber in dem Moment, wo man ähm Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt
Also so, dass auch wirklich niemand anders die Nachrichten lesen kann, außer Absender und Empfänger, findet ja die Verschlüsselung und Entschlüsselung auf den Endgeräten statt. Und dafür hat,
Schlüssel und die Nachricht ist also so verschlüsselt in dem Fall, wenn ich jetzt hier dem Tim eine schicke, ist die Sofaschlüsse, dass nur der Themen diese Nachricht entschlüsseln kann.
Und ähm in dem Moment, wo ich so etwas mache, ist natürlich entscheidend, dass ich weiß, dass ich die Nachricht so verschlüssele, dass sie auch
nur der Tim entschlüsseln kann. Das ist nämlich, dass ich sie mit dem Schlüssel verschlüssele den Tim hat. Und nicht zum Beispiel mit dem Schlüssel den WhatsApp,
oder der Ulf. Und ähm da
der kommt also dem dem Prüfen des Schlüssels. Eine besondere Bedeutung zu, die so bedeutsam ist, dass sie im Prinzip äh wahrscheinlich das große Problem der der weitläufigen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung war, der
weit verbreiteten Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung in den letzten zwanzig Jahren. Und ähm,
Und letztendlich ist der Durchbruch in diesem Bereich, denke ich, den kann man schon da maximal ins Bike äh äh ähm zugestehen, der mit dem Messenger Signal ähm,
diese Schlüsselprüfung ähm im Prinzip so weit wie möglich vom Nutzer weggetan hat
und einfach nur sagt, okay, am ersten, beim ersten Mal gibt's einen Schlüssel, fertig, dem wird vertraut, da machen wir gar keine großartige weitere Prüfung. Aber wenn sich der ändert.
Wenn sich der Schlüssel ändert, dann unterbrechen wir die Kommunikation und sagen,
Der Schlüssel hat sich gerade geändert, klicke hier, um das zu bestätigen, dass wir dich darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt haben.
Und dann wird die Nachricht quasi mit dem neuen Schlüssel nochmal gesendet, damit der Empfänger sie entschlüsseln kann.
Genau und ich glaube an der Stelle ist es wichtig, dass man ganz kurz dran erinnert, dass es im Wesentlichen zwei Szenarien gibt, warum sich ein Schlüssel ändern kann. Szenario eins ist völlig legitim. Ich habe
wie die IFF in ihrem Blogpost so schön schreibt. Ich habe als Empfänger mein Handy irgendwie in den See geworfen aus Versehen und ich habe jetzt ein neues Handy, ich habe Signal neu installiert. Es wird ein neuer
generiert für mich, also neuer öffentlicher Schlüssel für mich generiert und den Funk, mein Handy an den Signalserver und dann sagt der eben oh lalala, neuer Schlüssel, das könnte nämlich auch illegitim sein und zwar das ist Szenario zwei
irgendein ganz böser Angreifer möchte diese Nachricht mitlesen, die NSA oder sonst irgendwer und schiebt quasi dem Signalserver an meiner Stelle einen neuen Papier unter. Das ist das böse Sinner
Area. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, das hast du ja gerade sehr schön dargestellt, wie gehe ich als Betreiber eines Kommunikationsdienstes mit so einem Schlüsselwechsel um? Und Signal hat quasi den, ich sage mal, Paranoiden Proud und sie sagen oh Schlüsselwechsel ist
Im Zweifel gefährlich und warnt den User und es wird die Nachricht eben nicht automatisch nochmal verschlüsselt mit dem neuen Ke.
Sie blockieren das quasi.
Es gibt, es gibt noch einen dritten Fall, der noch mit da reinkommt. Äh bei Single ist es ja auch derzeit so, dass es halt sich nur auf ein Gerät bezieht
So und wenn man halt mit mehreren Geräten kommunizieren möchte, man hat ein iPhone, man hat ein iPad, man hat noch irgendwie einen Rechner, et cetera, dann braucht ja im Prinzip auch jedes Gerät nochmal ein weiteres Schlüssel, da ist immer dieses Problem, wenn ein neues Gerät hinzukommt
Wie kommt das hinzu, ja? Also auch das äh.
Das geht ja bei Signal gar nicht, ne? Das ist ja dann.
Signal Desktop Client. Seit Monaten im Betrieb.
Ja? Und der macht das dann wie.
Müsste ich Lilli ja mal fragen, wie sie das umgesetzt hat, aber ich glaube, der, der.
Keine Warnung oder was.
Herr Wunder, der singt sich mit dem Telefon, das heißt, du hast dann im Grunde zwei Legs. Du hast einmal die sichere äh Kommunikation zwischen deinem Telefon und dem Telefon deines Kommunikationspartners und dann hast du nochmal einen zweiten Secure-Channel zwischen der Desktop-App und deinem Handy. Deswegen scannst du ja diesen QA-Code ein auf deinem Handy. Das ist im Grunde dann äh der Schlüsselaustausch zwischen der App
äh auf dem Desktop und.
Ah okay, gut, dann.
Übrigens genauso.
Dann ist das nur so ein, so ein, so ein, also bei iMessage ist es ja zum Beispiel anders.
Bei einem ist es anders, weil nämlich dann mit deiner Apple ID einfach eine Menge Pupkies verbunden werden, also von jedem Endgerät ein eigener Papi.
Um nochmal kurz zu den Punkt zu kommen, also der Schlüssel ändert sich. So und der es ist ganz klar, der häufigste von den eben beschriebenen Fällen wird sein
WhatsApp neu installiert, Handy in See geworfen, anderes Handy gekauft, vergessen den Kiez zu Backupen. Das heißt, in den meisten Fällen werden die Leute wird es eine völlig unbedeutsame
Situation sein, dass sich dieser Schlüssel geändert hat. Und deswegen hat sogar WhatsApp
Paddyfold, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, dann muss ich jetzt vorsichtig sein, weil ich das ja nicht nutze. Ähm die dies das Setting ausgeschaltet,
dass man Motiv, dass man eine Warnung bekommt, wenn sich der Schlüssel ändert.
Ist aus, ja.
Das kann man anmachen. Ähm.
Und ähm dann warnt WhatsApp. Und jetzt kommt der Unterschied zwischen WhatsApp und Signal. WhatsApp warnt dich, sorgt aber dafür, dass die Nachricht, die du ja unter Umständen gerade bekommen hast, die noch mit dem alten Schlüssel verschlüsselt war,
direkt nochmal gesendet wird mit dem Neuen. Und quasi die Warnung, der Schlüssel hat sich geändert, hat äh von der Funktionsweise her kein,
macht keinen technischen Unterschied. Du kriegst die Nachricht einfach mit dem neuen Schlüssel, es wird nur gesagt, da hat sich jetzt gerade was geändert. Und das äh ermöglicht ein.
Ein Angriffsszenario, dass du quasi ein Rekeing einer noch nicht empfangsbestätigten Nachricht.
Erzwingen kannst. Durch den Wechsel des Schlüssels. Also äh in dem Moment, wo äh Tim jetzt meine, ich sende Tim eine Nachricht, in dem Moment, wo Tims Handy mir,
signalisiert, ich habe die äh gelesen, Empfangsbestätigung, ab dann sagt mein WhatsApp, die schicke ich nie wieder mit einem anderen Schlüssel. Wenn ich aber die Empfangsbestätigung nicht bekomme und stattdessen.
Mir gesagt, wir schicken mal mit einem anderen Schlüssel, dann wird mein WhatsApp das automatisch tun. Signal hingegen nicht.
Single würde erst das okay zu dem neuen Schlüssel abwarten und dann erst auf den Rekeing Recrest antworten. Ja. Nee, sogar gar nicht, ich glaube, da musste sogar manuell neu schicken, ne? Also ich glaube.
Ja, genau, du musst glaube ich dann nochmal ähm so der, der ähm.
Der Scherz darin ist, jetzt wird IZ ist also ein ein Vorschein gegangen, hat gesagt, das ist hier eine eine Hintertür, wie man einen Angriff auf die Verschlüsselung machen kann,
der Nutzer keine Möglichkeit hat, den zu unterbinden. Es geht jederzeit, solange die Nachricht nicht empfangsbestätigt ist, zack an den Schlüssel unterschieben, WhatsApp schickt dir automatisch äh durch. Das heißt, es gibt hier eine eine Möglichkeit für WhatsApp.
Nachrichten zu entschlüsseln. Gibt's ohnehin, wenn die Keyprüfung nicht vernünftig ist, deswegen war es auch so ein bisschen äh interessant, weil wenn die, wenn die Edi per die Kies nicht verifizieren, ist,
de facto die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung wertlos, kannst du auch einfach sein lassen, ne? Wenn du die Kies nicht verifizierst, äh, kannst du das auch einfach sein lassen.
Ähm zumindest aus einer fundamentalen Perspektive, wenn du sagst, du bist edwords neu, du möchtest über WhatsApp kommunizieren.
Ja, die Frage ist halt glaube ich immer, was ist, wie heißt das so schön dein Fred Model, ne? Wo gegen welche Angriffe willst du dich eigentlich schützen? Und ich glaube, dass WhatsApp
äh die Kommunikation Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, das hilft jedenfalls schon mal gegenüber den dem,
Standardgeheimdienste einfach auf der Übertragungsstrecke mit dem ganz großen Schnorchel rangeht, ne, weil einfach auf der Übertragungsstrecke erstmal alles unlesbar ist, es sei denn, du gehst gezielt gegen einzelne Endgeräte vor und versuchst dann deinen Schlüssel abzugreifen. Also klar, gegen NSA
Target Operations kannst du natürlich einpacken. Aber ich glaube dann ist Signal oder WhatsApp auch nicht dein einziges Problem, sondern ist im Zweifel dein IO ist das Problem.
Die die zwingen dich eh im Zweifel oder die die schicken dir einen Trojaner aufs Handy oder sonst was, ne? Aber das heißt äh es gibt zumindest schon mal keine ähm oder im Zweifelsfall keine Massenüberwachung, äh die dabei, die da bei WhatsApp stattfinden kann. Es gibt keine Bike-Data-Collection
aber es gibt diese es gibt einen dokumentierte und nachvollziehbare Möglichkeit für WhatsApp ähm
theoretisch, denn in der Praxis gibt's da keinen Beleg, für das das geschieht ein Angriff auf deine auf deine Ende zu Ende,
Verschlüsselung vorzunehmen.
Kann man machen, ja, aber ist das jetzt eine Backdoor? Ninus.
Also ich würde sagen, ist einfach prinzipiell keine keine saubere Implementierung von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung und die Erwägungen, die dafür,
angeführt werden, dass das so implementiert zu haben ähm.
Sind aus dieser Usability-Perspektive zumindest nachvollziehbar.
Genau, so würde ich das nämlich auch sehen, ja.
Es ist ganz klar und das ist, denke ich, die entscheidende Warnung hier, WhatsApp ist kein besonders sicherer Messenger
und äh man, wenn man jetzt mit Edwards Norden ähm äh Datenhelerei begehen möchte, ähm bevor die Verfassungsbeschwerde von von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte durch ist,
dann ist man gut beraten äh sich auf eine andere Kommunikationsalternative ähm,
ähm äh zu zu beschränken und nicht ausgerechnet äh sich nicht ausgerechnet die kritische Kommunikation über ein Unternehmen zu führen, das für neunzehn Milliarden von Facebook gekauft.
Ja. Und dann natürlich auch der, das Stichwort Metadaten, ne? Also wer mit wem kommuniziert, wird ja sowieso für durch Ende zu Ende als solche erstmal nicht verschlüsselt oder verborgen, ne?
Fällt eh dort, fällt eh dort nochmal also als Meterdaten an.
Auch bei Facebook, ne.
Ist alles, es ist alles ist nicht besonders gut. Also gemessen daran, dass das ein Messenger ist, der Facebook gehört
Der Meterdatendaten sammelt wenigstens Gutes. Der diese Meterdaten mit dem Facebookdatensatz zusammenführen möchte,
ist dann diese Sicherheitslücke in der Krypto wahrscheinlich nicht das die größte Sorge, die man als WhatsApp-Nutzer haben sollte.
Das würde ich ehrlich gesagt genauso sehen und ähm apropos du sagst nun, da warten wir noch auf das Indoors. Ich glaube, das Norden ist noch nicht Fördermitglied bei der GF.
Oh, ah ja, dann wählen wir ihm mal Bescheid sagen, das geht so.
Nee, aber ich ich finde auch, also äh da jetzt so auf WhatsApp rumzuhacken
Also klar ist, man kann das ein Designfloor nennen, aber ich finde das, ich finde das schon ehrlich gesagt total verständlich, denn es ist eben ein heiß umkämpfter Markt und sie bringen schon mehr Verschlüsselung in den Massenmarkt, ne?
Das interessante ist, er also muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, WhatsApp ähm mit dem Ausrollen des Signalprotokolls bei WhatsApp ähm
das war in der Welt der größte, das größte Ausrollen von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, dass wir je gesehen haben. Jetzt eben leider einer
weitestgehend wertlosen, aber ich finde das ganz interessant, die äh Oxi Malins Bike, der Entwickler des Signalprotokolls und auch des Signal Messengers und so ähm verargumentiert, warum WhatsApp hier nicht den Nachrichten,
bricht, sondern ihn durchgehen lässt und er sagt also klar, erstens die Usability-Sache, die meisten unserer Nutzer wollen kommunizieren und wenn der Messenger nicht kommuniziert, dann finden die Messenger nicht gut.
Ähm und zweitens sagt er würden wir blockieren an dieser Stelle,
dann könnte WhatsApp ähm erkennen, wer seine Kies vergleicht und wer nicht.
Also einfacher Fall, ne? Tim wirft sein äh iPhone, ist ja hier auch ein älteres Modell ähm in den Teich. Ich will doch nur scherzen. Ich wusste, dass ich dich damit wieder aufgeweckt kriege. Ähm Tim wirft sein iPhone in den Teich. Ähm.
Bestenfalls mit fünf S. Tim, was ich da sehe.
SE
Ach so.
Aber nicht verfreake schon. Wir haben nur noch, wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Ähm.
Moderne Scheiße.
Also Tim wirft sein Handy in den Teich, ähm,
holt sich eine andere Schlüssel, ändert sich. Ich schreibe ihm eine Nachricht, mein WhatsApp äh kriegt kriegt Bescheid neuer Key, schickt die Nachricht sofort dahin.
Ich sage aber, oh mein Gott, Tim, äh, ich rufe ihn dann auf einem anderen Kanal ein und sage, lass uns mal Kies vergleichen. WhatsApp weiß dann nicht,
ob ich die Kies wirklich prüfe oder nicht. Wenn WhatsApp sich verhalten würde wie Signal und an der Stelle blockiert.
Wüste WhatsApp ab dem Moment a der Linus schickt seine Nachricht nicht sofort wieder, das heißt er hat das Feature an, dass er die Fingerprints von den Kies checkt
Also auf Linus dürfen wir niemals einen solchen Angriff machen. Das ist die Argumentation von Maximal in Zweig. Ähm
die natürlich auch ein bisschen um viele Ecken geht ähm ob das jetzt noch das eine Meter Datum äh wäre, was man WhatsApp dann nicht mehr zugestehen sollte. Sei dahin gestellt. Ich
persönlich äh bevorzuge Messenger, die äh mir ein vernünftiges Prüfen, der Fingerprints ermöglichen und auch da ist Signal jetzt nicht äh das Paradebeispiel.
Es soll sein? Also ich habe nämlich heute gerade die Bitte bekommen von einem Kollegen, der wollte gerne meine Single ID haben. Ich habe also mindestens zwei Minuten in dem Messenger rumgeklickt, ich habe keine ID oder keinen QA-Code gefunden, gibt's sowas?
Du musst irgendwie oben, wenn du mit jemandem kommunizierst, oben draufdrücken, fünf Sekunden gehalten und dann.
OK und das geht nur bei Vollmond wahrscheinlich irgendwie, ne.
Ich, also ich hab's auch, ich habe auch äh lange Zeit gedacht, diese Funktion gäbe es gar nicht.
Gibt es aber, ok.
Ist, wenn du sie dann nutzt, ähm dann kannst du dir sagen lassen, dass dieser Kies stimmt. Guck mal hier, also ich gehe jetzt hier, werden wir heute geschrieben, dann gucke ich hier.
Ja. Ach, da oben geht es. Ja.
Very five safety Number. Und das Schöne ist, jetzt kannst du deinen, jetzt kannst du meinen Code scannen, dann sagt er, jo stimmt.
Gut, aber der, aber der sagt dann.
Ach so. Aber der sagt dann. Der die ID kriegst du aber nicht.
Du machst eine Kommunikation auf, also.
Auch mal sehen bitte. Ich habe das nämlich auch noch nicht.
Ja dann mach eine Kommunikation auf, klick oben auf den Namen.
Ach so geht.
Safety Number. Aber jetzt kommt der Knüller, wenn du den Code jetzt scannst, ne, dann wird der dir sagen, jo stimmt, das ist die, die du hast.
Aber Sharen kannst du die doch.
Ja Moment, was er nicht macht und jetzt kommt der er sagt ähm er macht jetzt nicht zum Beispiel, wenn äh wenn Ulf jetzt wenn ich jetzt und von Ulf den Code scanne und Ulf meinen.
Dann wäre das, was wir uns wünschen würden, eigentlich, dass wir so einen grünen Punkt daneben k.
Sowie bei Shrima.
Hasse, Hasse verifiziert, das ist jetzt sicher, das ist der Key,
äh den du hast, ja macht macht äh Signal nicht. Also auch Signal hat da einige ähm einige wirkliche haarsträubende Trade-Offs
im im Umgang mit den Schlüsseln, die die dann, sage ich mal, in der, in der Krypto-Community dann doch auch sehr viel Kritik äh und Scruden nie erfahren, aber ähm.
Was bringt's denn denn überhaupt den zu überprüfen, wenn man's nicht angezeigt.
Das ist die Frage, die man dann sich nochmal stellen müsste.
Ach guck mal, das ist ja interessant.
Jetzt will ich nicht in die Messenger gehen, ja, dann gibt's ja bei Streamer hat man da dann das Schöne, dass dass da die die ID ähm eine Ableitung aus dem
Key ist und und nicht die Telefonnummer. Es gibt eine ganze Leute, die ganze Reihe Leute, die ungern ihre Telefonnummer teilen, weil dann kann man ja auch angerufen werden
über GSM getrackt werden und was es da nicht alles für Scherze gibt. Dann gibt's wieder Leute, die Signal einfach auf ihre Festnetztelefonnummer registrieren, was auch äh eine sehr elegante Methode ist, die die funktioniert. Aber lassen wir das. Ich würde sagen, äh es gibt viele Gründe, WhatsApp nicht zu nutzen, ähm das, was jetzt gefunden wurde, ist
einer davon, aber im Zweifelsfall nicht der Gewichtigste.
Ich sage auch mal was nochmal dazu. Man sieht hier auch Verschlüsselung,
Alles wichtig, alles richtig, alles gut und so weiter, aber auch damit kriegt man nie alle Fälle abgedeckt. Auch da gibt's immer äh wieder andere Konstellationen, wo man sich halt fragen muss, wenn ich jetzt hier wirklich Vertraulichkeit äh suche,
muss es unbedingt über den digitalen Weg gehen,
ja, da man hat nicht unbedingt immer die Möglichkeit, sondern es ist auch gut, solche Systeme zu haben, aber so äh ein Vollvertrauen in äh Systeme selbst, wenn sie noch so Open Source und noch so gut gemeint sind, äh ist halt einfach schwierig, weil es einfach auch technische T.
Da fällt mir noch ein schöner Gag ein bei der Pressekonferenz für Datenhederei. Am Freitag äh super Frage von Falk Steiner, Korrespondent vom Deutschlandradio, der nämlich fragte, ob man die Datenhederei nicht einfach umgehen kann, indem man Dinge ausdruckt. Und skurrilerweise ist das so.
Also ja. Ja, das ist das, ja, ich sage nur, das ist ein Gesetz für Internetausdrucker, ja,
Das ist ja wirklich so, weil eben der Datenbegriff Voraussetzt, dass die Dinge nicht unmittelbar wahrnehmbar sind. Wenn ich also mal als Ministerialbeamter mein League ausdrucke
und den dann weitergebe in einen Journalisten, ähm dann verbege ich zwar als, als äh als Beamter noch meine mein Geheimnis verrat, aber als Journalist kann ich das
beliebig weiter streuen. Ich habe wenigstens mal einscanne, habe ich ein Problem. Ist völlig absurd. Also.
Jetzt machst du da einen riesen Aufwand und in Wirklichkeit ist.
Alles ganz einfach.
In Wirklichkeit ist das nur ein Lobbyinitiative des Papierindustriellen Komplex.
Werdet, werdet Internetausdrucker.
Und ein letzter Punkt zu diesem Stichwort äh Messenger, da wollte ich nochmal ganz kurz auf die Meta-Ebene gehen. Ja, wir sind ja hier, ne? Äh
Stichwort Guardian, der das ja ganz groß gebracht hat, irgendwie die, dieser, dieser Fund war ja schon irgendwie aus dem letzten Jahr und der Guardian hat's aber jetzt gerade erst groß hoch
Brangie, Riesenbackboard und so. Ähm das ist aber auch ein Medienversagen, ne? Also da muss natürlich ein Journalist oder eine Journalistin. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in diesem Fall ist, muss natürlich so ein bisschen recherchieren. Was bedeutet denn das jetzt eigentlich, anstatt da so eine Riesenwelle zu machen und zu sagen, WhatsApp ist unsicher, ne? Also
Wir haben ja die Probleme von WhatsApp angesprochen, aber ähm eigentlich war das auch eine Form von Fake News, ne. Jedenfalls die Einschätzung war Fake News.
Der äh der Forscher, der der diese Schwachstelle muss man ja auch sagen, ist eine Schwachstelle, ne.
Ja, ist.
Der Forscher, der diese Schwachstelle äh entdeckt hat, hatte sie eben auch äh an an WhatsApp äh reported und die haben dann eben auch einige Monate nichts äh nichts gemacht und dann hat er da eben jetzt nochmal mehr Öffentlichkeit für zugesucht zu diesem
zu diesem Vorkommnis. Also ich esse.
Also du meinst, der hat das ein bisschen hochgejäst, auch der der Reporter. Äh Quatsch, der, der, der Forscher.
Ich tue mich da schwer, weil es ist eine Schwachstelle, ne? Es ist eine, es ist eine Schwachstelle und ähm diese Schwachstelle wird vom Hersteller mit nachvollziehbaren,
Argumenten begründet, Nachvollziehbar heißt nicht, dass ich diese Argumente teile, aber sie sind äh wir du hattest das mal sehr schön gesagt, vertretbar war so ein,
Diese Argumente sind vertretbar. Man kann das Argument machen, es ist kein Fake News, dieses Argument, ja? Und ähm insofern, da ich so gemessen an den anderen Problemen von WhatsApp ist das nicht das Größte.
Hätte ein ein Messenger, den ich ähm also signal würde ich das zum Beispiel nicht verzeihen,
die gleiche Schwäche. Muss man mal ein bisschen schauen mit ne? Und insofern ähm.
Wobei ich glaube die, dass eigentlich die eigentliche Schwäche ist aus meiner Sicht eher die die Forteinstellung als dass es überhaupt einen Rike gi.
Genau, das genau das ist es, ja, dass sie dir sie verkaufen, sie verkaufen irgendwie diesen Messenger, der dich nicht warnt
wenn sich die Kies ändern und das ist das ist was viel, viel, viel, viel schlimmer als das im Falle eines eines Kiewechsels eine automatische äh Retrendsmission äh stattfindet, die dich unter Umständen im Falle eines Männende Mittelangriffs
eben dieser den Inhalt dieser einen Nachricht kosten könnte
während du paddyfold äh einfach äh gegen jegliche Form von Man in den Mittelangriff äh verwundbar bist und noch nicht mal davor gewarnt wirst. Also das ist das ist die sehr viel größere Schwachstelle da,
Ich glaube, dann haben wir das jetzt halbwegs eingeordnet und das heißt nicht, dass wir äh WhatsApp äh entdorsten oder diese Schwachstelle äh runter äh spielen wollen. Aber es äh sie ist also da und ähm.
Ist aber nicht das Schlimmste, was es bei WhatsApp zu monieren gibt.
So schaut das aus, ne? Jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt, wir haben die Lage in Nation, abschließend der Örter. Das ist natürlich ein ganz jung.
Nee, es gibt noch andere Nationen. Wir sind ja hier äh nicht so nationalistisch unterwegs. Wir gucken uns die äh äh nochmal eine kleine Gesetzgebung an die äh Barack Obama jetzt irgendwie mit auf.
Ach, wir sind noch gar nicht durch. Ich dachte.
Nee, wir sind zwar schon an seinem an Linus Zeitlimit angekommen, aber noch nicht am Ende seiner Notizen.
Da geht noch einiges.
Zwei Sachen, also einmal.
Ähm hat äh The Rack Obama jetzt noch irgendwie ein ein etwas komisches Abschiedsgeschenk an die NSA verteilt. Die darf nämlich jetzt ihre ungefilterten Rohdaten, die sie so in der globalen Überwachung ansammelt mit äh mit anderen
US-Geheimdiensten teilen. Ähm bisher ähm.
Konnten sie das zwar auch tun, allerdings äh unter äh unter sogenannten Minimierungsregeln, das heißt, da wurden ähm.
Nichtrelevante Daten rausgenommen, insbesondere die Daten von Unschuldigten oder nicht Verdächtigten wurden von der NSA aussortiert und wurden dann.
Den anderen Behörden gegeben. Die anderen Behörden sind also die sechzehn Mitglieder des Intellet der Intelligenz Community, der des IC.
Sechzehn Community. Sechzehn Behörden gibt's da.
Wir haben den Link da unten im Pad, müsste der sein. Nee, hör mal nicht.
Kannst aber einfach, wenn du Members auf die IC googelst, dann findest du, das ist also dann CIA, DIA, DJ S, FBI, aber auch irgendwie, was weiß ich, der, die haben ja für jeden für jeden Mist gehandelt, sie haben ja irgendwie viel für Agri geholt, für für Agrarökonomie, einen Geheimdienst oder sowas.
Ja als Kanzlerin also Members of the IC ähm müsste ein Link sein, der oder ein Google-Ergebnis sein, was wir auch nochmal da hinzufügen sollen. Also die die Änderung, die hier stattfindet, ist früher hat die NSA die Datenbereinigung gemacht,
Ähm und jetzt ähm machen die Behörden das selber.
Ähm die Einschränkungen, die damit einhergehen ist, die Anfrage muss vom Leiter einer Behörde oder zumindest von einem hochrangigen Mitarbeiter kommen. Das ist natürlich eine praktisch nicht relevante.
Einmal, ne?
Die wird einfach abgestempelt, ne? Man muss begründen, wie und warum ein Dienst die Daten nutzen will und warum es keine Alternative gibt,
Da schreibst du im Prinzip auch nur einmal, ne? Wir kennen das ja aus den aus den deutschen Gesetzesvorschlägen, Alternativen keine. Ähm,
Und die anfragende Behörde.
Muss sich verpflichten, dass sie sich an die zwanzig vierzehn von US-Präsident Obama eingeführte äh direktive achtundzwanzig hält
Äh und diese achten die Limit, die Direktive achtundzwanzig begrenzt die Verwendung von Daten, sowohl von US-Bürgern, als auch von Ausländern
in der Bike Data Collection. Ja, also da gibt's nochmal Einschränkungen ähm und ähm man darf das nicht tun,
um den politischen Prozess in den USA zu beeinflussen ähm und man darf keine Suchbegriffe verwenden, die darauf ausgelegt sind, dass die Daten von US-Bürgern direkt hervorheben.
Aber letztendlich ähm Fakt ist, es bleibt hier eine Ausweitung des äh Teilens der Daten zwischen NSA und den an,
ausnahmslos den anderen Inlands und Auslandsgeheimdiensten der USA. Insbesondere auch des FBI, das ja ähm.
Dann doch eher im Bereich der Strafverfolgung angeordnet ist als im Bereich
der der Geheimdienst Datensammlung. Dieses Trennungsgebot scheint es offenbar in den USA,
nicht in der Form oder in dem Ausmaß zu geben, wie wir es in Deutschland hochhalten. Äh du hast da ja mal ein bisschen dich mit mehr mit US-Recht auseinandergesetzt. Ähm ich weiß nicht, wie genau du kennst, ob ob es bei denen überhaupt irgendwie so ein
Trennungsgebot.
Ist mir noch nie untergekommen. Er ist mir noch nie untergekommen, also jede Behörde hat natürlich ihre eigenen Regeln, aber ähm Trennungsgebot, in dem Sinne gibt's nicht, wobei man ja immer sagen muss, bei uns ist das ja auch eher eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine Art politische,
Tradition, als wirklich ein Rechtsgrundsatz, ne? Es wird immer so getan, als wenn das irgendwo im Grundgesetz stünde, das ist nicht
Studien nirgendwo, also es ist Rechtsprechung, ähm das schon, aber äh im Grundgesetz findest du das nicht, das Rennungsgebot.
Interessant, interessant, ich hätte, ich wäre davon ausgegangen, dass das in irgendeiner Form formalisiert ist.
Nee, nee und es ist ja inzwischen äh auch sehr weitgehend aufgeweicht durch die Austausch äh Dateien. Zum einen Stichwort Antiterror-Datei äh und äh durch die Austauschzentren, ne, Stichwort gemeinsames Terrorabwehrzentrum. Also,
Das Trennungsgebot als politisches Prinzip klingt erstmal gut, aber in der Praxis ist da jetzt nicht mehr so irre, viel davon übrig geblieben.
Insbesondere auch durch die Doppelzuständigkeiten, dass also häufig Polizei und Geheimdienste für dieselben Themen zuständig sind auf diese Art und Weise näherst du dich dann denselben Leuten von zwei verschiedenen Seiten und tauscht dann beim GTAZ zum Beispiel die Daten aus.
Oder über eine Antiterrordatei.
Verrückt, die ARD, die Datenverarbeitung, das heißt echt das papierlose Büro.
Verrückt. Ja, ich meine, in effizient ist das, ne, das ist nicht der Punkt. Äh wobei das so diese
Doppelzuständigkeiten sind nicht effizient. Also da gibt's ja immer wieder auch Beispiele, gerade den Fall Arnis Amri, äh dass die Doppelzuständigkeiten letztlich dazu führen, dass die äh Aufgaben deutlich schlechter erfüllt werden, als wenn es jetzt nur die Polizei machen würde, zum Beispiel, deswegen ja, die alte Forderung ähm gerade die Terror,
eben nicht die Geheimdienste machen zu lassen, ne? Das sieht man am Fall Amri, wie das, wie das eben zu Problemen führt, noch viel krasser ist aber der Fall dieses sächsischen Attentäters, der ja dann auf
allerletzten Drücker noch erwischt wurde, ähm weil.
Du meinst den Sprengstoffsammler.
Ja, den nee, nee, nee, ich meine, den, ich meine, den Typen, der da jetzt letzten Endes dann ähm in Leipzig verhaftet wurde und sich dann im Gefängnis aufgehängt hatte.
Oh ja.
Da war es nämlich auch so, die Daten kamen über BKA und BNL, über den BND rein und anstatt das dann gleich beim Generalbundesanwalt und beim BKA anzusiedeln
zum Verfassungsschutz geschoben und der hat dann äh aus aus mir persönlich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen, die ähm
Landespolizei eingeschaltet und die haben das dann ja um ein Haar versaut, also jedenfalls konnte, ja, was heißt um ein Haarversaal, also er konnte halt einfach abhauen, ne? Die die Überwachung äh ähm hat nicht geklappt und der Zugriff hat nicht funktioniert.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Kommen wir nochmal kurz zu dem Thema der Angriff im Wahljahr zurück. Also es ist wirklich ich ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich glaube, kaum ein Thema hat.
Die deutsche Medienoffen Öffentlichkeit über einen solchen Zeitraum beschäftigt, ohne inhaltlich nennenswerte Fortschritte zu machen, wie.
Hackerangriffe im Wahljahr,
Das ist, ich weiß nicht, wann ich davor mohne, also gefühlt Monaten wahrscheinlich anderthalb Monaten oder sowas ähm,
zum ersten Mal äh was zugesagt habe, dann ja, war's irgendwann nochmal Wochen später im Deutschlandradio, ein Interview, wo ich da ein bisschen was zu ausgeführt hatte. Ähm,
und dann wurde das Avace nochmal Thema beim beim dreiunddreißig C drei,
und ist es jetzt wieder, also das bleibt es auch, ne? Also kommst, komm eigentlich ein konstanter äh Strom, ein ein konstanter Strahl, goldener Strahl an Anfragen äh zum Hacking.
Also auch jetzt beim quasi beim Club.
Kommen beim Club an oder oder dann auch bei mir direkt mal,
und und das Interessante ist, dass das, sage ich mal, das Niveau der an, also dass der Informationsstand,
ist immer der gleiche von dem gefragt wird, obwohl das Thema schon X mal durchgekaut ist. Das habe ich in dem äh in dem Maße bisher selten erlebt.
Es geht überhaupt nicht voran, würdest du sagen, die Diskus.
Es gibt keine die Diskussion entwickelt sie nicht, ich erkläre immer wieder, ja wie wie können Hackerangriffe funktionieren, welche funktionieren nicht, welche Probleme haben wir, welche nicht, ne?
Und äh das Thema bleibt, ne? Dann gibt's immer wieder ja und was der Russe, was der Usse nicht
ja und äh aber das Thema kommt nicht voran. Wie dem auch sei, ähm weil es nicht vorankommt, musst du jetzt äh äh Demazier hatte ja schon gesagt, dass er diese Angriffe,
aktiv bekämpfen möchte, was noch eine etwas nebulöse Ankündigung war und äh Hans-Georg Maaßen vom äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz äh sagte dann.
Der Nato Nine, wir möchten bitteschön mit Gegenangriffen antworten. Also ähm wir wollen.
Zurückzeibern. Ja und jetzt äh so wäre, wenn wir wissen, woher der Angriff kommt, dann wollen wir den Server zurückhacken und wir wollen jetzt endlich, also wir wollen jetzt hier Fullskals, Cyberware, äh so.
Heute wird zurückgezabert.
Könnte man das interpretieren? Und das ist ein bisschen überraschend. Ähm,
Also wenn du da jetzt sagst du, du willst zurückzeibern, ne, dann äh ist hast du natürlich erstmal das Attributsproblem. Wenn wenn der wenn der Russe aufgeheizt von Vladi.
Der Russe.
Ich ich will diese diese kalt wir es ist Kaltkriegsthema.
Der Russe. Das erinnert mich immer an meinen Großvater.
Ja natürlich, also ich mache das auch absichtlich.
Mein Großvater, das würde ich nie vergessen, der saß immer sei in seinem Fernsehsessel und wenn es irgendwie dann in den Achtzigern im Fernsehen um die Sowjetunion ging, dann dann entfiel äh entfuhr es ihm immer so, der Russe rüstet. Ich sag's euch, ich war da. Ja, der Russe Rüst.
Oder der Ivan, ne?
Der Russe, der Russe war's.
Ja, ich, also ich habe auch.
Der rüstet doch, ich sag's euch.
Sagen ja auch der Armi, ne? Also.
Ich sage das, wenn dann hier immer äh mit mit Smiley, der ähm ich habe übrigens.
Es ist fast so schön wie früher.
Dieses Deutschlandradiointerview, was ich gerade äh erwähnt hatte oder das hatte ich damals ähm gebloggt und habe äh unter dem Titel irgendwie der Russe manipuliert die Wahl mit vier Ausrufezeichen,
und und hatte dann auch sofort irgendwie so Kommentare irgendwie so unreflektiertes NATO-Sprech und so, ne? Da ist ja diese ganzen.
Nato sprech.
Na ja, also ähm,
Die Frage ist, äh wenn jetzt wirklich, wenn es so ist, dass äh wenn wir mal annehmen, dass tatsächlich Vladimir Putin die Order herausgibt, äh dass ähm.
Dass äh wir äh dass dass der Deutsche Bundestag zu hacken sei, ne? Dann.
Deutsche muss doch zu hacken sein.
Genau, dann wird dieser Angriff aber nicht stattfinden von einem Computer, der irgendwie im Kreml steht, ne, sondern die werden sich halt äh klassischer Hackertechniken äh bedienen und werden,
sich andere Serverhacken, äh Anonymisierungsnetzwerke oder Dienste nutzen und dann irgendwie von dort aus so angreifen, dass es am Ende nicht zu unterscheiden ist von dem Angriff eines eines Skript-Kiddies, ja? Das ist das, was wir bei solch bei erdeartigen Angriffen immer wieder sehen, dass
genau keine äh besonders äh elaborierten Cyberwaffen zum Einsatz kommen, sondern eher so Tool Kids und so, damit man eben auch wirklich einfach, damit jeder,
Techniker sagt, ja okay, komm, das hat der, das haben die hier von Gitarr, das ist hier ist nix Wildes, ne? Der ähm.
Könnte eine Regierungsorganisation sein, könnte aber auch einfach ein Teenager sein oder wie Donald Trump in eben auch mal sagte, Summer Ding on the Bad, Waying, for Hungry Pounds. So, das ist alles, das ist Absicht, es so aussehen zu lassen.
Das war schon auch ganz geil. Das muss man ihm sagen. Also hier und da hat der Donald ja schon auch einfach mal so so luzide Momente, ne?
Ja, der, der, also aber er hat ja, das war äh Einsatz vorher, hat er gesagt, dass sein sein zehnjähriger Sohn sich gut mit Computern auskennt und das ihn qualifiziert, diese Cyberthematik äh äh zu beurteilen. Also.
Cyber ist hart.
Wird er jetzt auch Cyber-Advisor eigentlich dann der Kleine, oder?
Nee, oh, das ist ein Thema, das sie hier gar nicht haben. Der Cyber-Advisor von Donald Trump wird Rudi Guiliani.
Der ist ah.
Und und dessen dessen hat irgendwie sechsundzwanzig Sicherheit.
Das heißt, Brudi Julianis, Drumler, kann man i.
Oh je, das müssen wir, als, jetzt müssen.
Aber gut, na gut, nicht schön.
Kommen wir nochmal zu den Cyberwaffen. Also Maaßen sitzt jetzt da und stellt fest, äh äh was weiß ich, ne? Der Russe greift an und jetzt muss er zurück zabern. Und ähm.
Warum das so so problematisch ist, ist erstens, du kannst gar nicht wissen, woher dieser Angriff kommt und und der ist auch wirklich eine etwas äh skurrile Vorstellung von
von Hackingangriffen
dass du quasi im Verlaufe des Hackingangriffs erkennst, wer dich gerade angreifst und dann zurückhäckst, ja? Also sowas gibt's im Fernsehen. Üblicherweise sitzt du auf einmal da, also bestenfalls erkennst du, dass du gerade angegriffen wirst
es gelingt dir noch, diesen Angriff irgendwie zu unterbinden, indem du ein vernünftiges Nordregel dafür schreibst oder so, ne? Oder oder von mir aus auch Statelist einfach dies blockierst oder sonst was, ja? Das, das wäre jetzt das Schönste der Gefühle und das wird dann auch schon eine eine sehr hohe technische Reife voraussetzen, so ein Angriff
festzustellen, während er noch im Gange ist und dann ja irgendwie offenbar vielleicht auch noch nicht erfolgreich oder n
teilweise erfolgreich. Das wäre so die die Königsklasse, dass du das mal schaffst, in den meisten Fällen sehe ich das ganz anders, ne? Dann,
siehst du Monate später äh auf einmal so ein äh irgendwie waren die Dateien gerade noch auf unserer Festplatte und jetzt sind sie irgendwie hier auf diesem, wie heißt das hier? Wiki League, so äh komisch. Ähm,
Also dieses Szenario, was er da heraufbeschwört, ist so ein bisschen komisch. Und zweitens hast du natürlich dann ähm,
du kannst dir ja dann nicht spontan ausdenken, mit welcher Sicherheitslücke du jetzt diesen Gegner heckst. Und wenn der diese Sicherheitslücke auch kennt, dann hat er sie nicht,
Das heißt, um zurück zu Cybern, brauchst du im Prinzip ein exklusives Wissen über Sicherheitslücken.
Du musst Schwachstellen kennen, die andere nicht kennen und deswegen haben.
Also quasi muss quasi horten für den Tag X.
Für den Tag X brauchst du sammelst du halt die ODs, kaufst die auf dem Schwarzmarkt
Ähm oder entwickelt sie selber, lässt sie selber erforschen, aber du nimmst dadurch auf jeden Fall in Kauf. Wenn du sagst, diese Sicherheitslücke, die der Öffentlichkeit noch nicht bekannt ist, halte ich zurück
In der Hoffnung, dass sie jemanden, den ich irgendwann mal angreifen möchte, auch nicht bekannt ist. Damit nimmst du automatisch in Kauf, dass die gesamte Welt,
zumindest aber dein Land, Deutschland, was du ja beschützen möchtest als äh als Verfassungsschützer,
Dieser Sicherheitslücke ebenso ausgesetzt ist und dass jemand, der sie kennt.
Eben dann auch Deutschland angreifen kann. Das heißt, du gehst da an eine, in eine, in eine Abwägung, die immer am Ende,
zu Ungunsten deiner eigenen Interessen ist.
Weil du nämlich deine eigenen Systeme unsicher hältst, weil du ja den Audien nicht bekannt geben darfst. Wenn du den natürlich reporten würdest, in irgend so einer Responcible Discloser, ähm Manie, äh Manier, dann ist er verbrannt, ja.
Verbrannt. Ja, das heißt du dein, was du machst ist, äh, du, du, äh, entweder entwickelst du selber die Kompetenzen, solche Lücken zu finden, was unwahrscheinlich ist, dass das äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz dann nennenswerte Kompetenzen hat.
Aber wir kriegen doch jetzt Zitis. Dann wird doch alles gut.
Ja mit mit ja also ich hatte ähm.
Ich muss dann noch gucken, wie ich mit diesem Wissen umgehe. Ich hatte da letztens eine eine Diskussion mit dem neuen Leiter der Citisbehörde, die unter den sogenannten Chatham House Roules verlief. Das heißt, ich darf äh zitieren, was dort gesagt wurde.
Aber nicht von wem? Nicht von wem? Mhm.
Aber nicht von wem äh und wenn man jetzt irgendwie die Äußerungen überzieht ist, dann zitiert, dann ist es natürlich irgendwie äh nicht.
Schwierig.
Schwierig äh die Darts darauf zu beziehen. Und deswegen muss ich noch ein bisschen gucken, ob ich die gleichen Äußerungen nicht auch einfach öffentlich finde, um mich darauf zu beziehen.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik liegen Dokumente vor.
Ich bin da wirklich, ich bin da gerade so ein bisschen, mir ist das ein bisschen ich muss noch irgendwie mal mit denen sprechen, wie man da jetzt verfährt, so, also wenn's diesen so eine Diskussionsrunde gibt, ich habe da ja auch einen Vortrag gehalten,
dessen Inhalte ich ja jetzt hier auch gerade vertrete, ja? Also die,
was ich selber sage, kann ich ja an anderer Stelle auch nochmal sagen, denn das wollte ich gerade nochmal kurz ausführen. Also wenn du sagst, du kaufst diese Lücken, also ist das Thema wir haben über das Thema gesprochen.
Ob man denn Sicherheitslücken kaufen dürfe.
Das kann ich ja auch sagen. Und ähm meine Argumentation ist eben, wenn du das machst, hälst du erstens diesen Schwarzmarkt Verunsicherheit an und da hast du doppelten doppelten Schaden. Wenn erstens treibst du da die Preise hoch,
Zweitens äh führst du dazu, dass diese Leute, von denen du die Sicherheitslücken kaufst, dir an anderer Stelle keine Responsible des Clowns machen,
jemand anders verkaufen, ja? Und ähm.
Das heißt, was da getan wird, ist grundsätzlich verkehrt. Weil es dazu führt, dass du ähm erstens die Leute davon wegführst,
zu betreiben, das heißt, du schneidest dir selber in deine Sicherheit rein, du kriegst keine Lücken mehr reportet.
Jedenfalls nicht umsonst, ne?
Jedenfalls nicht umsonst, zweitens, ähm, durch den Kauf der Lücken ähm will er hoffst du, dass sie
Weiter in der Welt existieren, du also selber auch darunter leidest oder deinen Start, den du ja je als Verfassungsschützer ähm äh schützen möchtest und drittens, du, du, du bremst quasi
den evolutionären Prozess, der dir die Sicherheit bringen könnte.
Die du eigentlich haben möchtest. Du möchtest ja, dass es äh also ist ein ganz normaler Kreislauf von,
äh Software entsteht, Unsicherheit ist drin, Unsicherheit wird gefunden, Unsicherheit wird beseitigt.
In diesem Rennen möchtest du bist du immer in der besseren Position wenn du die Sicherheit bekommst,
als wenn du der Versuchsexklusives Wissen über die Unsicherheit zu haben, denn dieses selbst das Wissen über die Unsicherheit unterliegt ja einem Verfall.
Denn es gibt ja immer noch, ne, zumindest noch, wer weiß, ob sich das dauerhaft hält. Die unabhängige Community, die jeder zahlt, die Sicherheitslücke, die du teuer gekauft hast, unabhängig feststellen
und schließen kann.
Also jedenfalls bei so einer, bei so einer iOS-Sicherheitslücke ist das Risiko enorm hoch, ne? Wie oft ist das schon vorgekommen, dass DJ Bray Community so eine Lücke gehortet hat? Frei nach dem Motto, lassen wir mal erstmal die nächste IOS-Version rauskommen und dann gab's nie einen Jaybreak, weil Apple ist nämlich unabhängig davon auch schon gefunden hat.
Es passiert ständig, ne?
Ja, das äh also es ist ein Wettlauf und dieser Wettlauf ähm in den kannst du als Player Deutschland, ja? Ähm, eintreten, aber mit deinen finanziellen Mitteln,
mit deiner Kompetenz hast du da keine Schnitte. Das heißt du bist besser bedient, wenn du sagst und vor allem ist ja der Witz. Er argumentiert ja hier, wir haben Angst vor Hackerangriffen im Wahljahr.
Als Konsequenz daraus wollen wir die Unsicherheit erhöhen.
Indem wir Owdays hor.
Indem wir Audreys horten, indem wir zurück angreifen, ja, statt zu sagen, äh Hackerangriffe im Wahljahr, hier sind zehn Millionen Euro,
Lösungen, die jetzt dafür sorgen, dass unsere Parlamentarier ihre Geheimnisse.
Vernünftig schützen.
Nicht auf Wiki Leaks finden. Da kann man ja gucken, ob Leute bereit sind, das für Geld zu tun oder nicht.
Ne, aber das es heißt quasi die Reaktion auf die Gefahr der Unsicherheit ist hier die Unsicherheit zu erhöhen statt die Sicherheit zu erhöhen. Ich halte das für fundamental falsch
Erstens aus äh ähm Grundrechtserwägungen aus Privatsphäre Erwägung und so weiter
aber eben auch aus der aus den eigenen Motivationen des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz im Rahmen der Spionageabwehr ähm die sie ja hier betreiben wollen.
Aber da weißt du, dass ich glaube, das Argument, das einfach alles trumm äh trumpft, ja, in im BMI und in bei der Zitis, beim Verfassungsschutz ist, wir müssen doch die Geräte von Gefährdern hacken können.
Es ist immer so die Vorstellung, wir müssen nach einer Online-Durchsuchung machen können, wir müssen doch eine Quellentickerü durchführen können und deswegen ich glaube, da setzt irgendwann das Denken aus, die wollen einfach um jeden Preis in die Geräte rein,
das merkst du ja im Grunde im ganzen Verlauf der Debatte, die gibt's ja schon seit etwa zweitausendfünf, zweitausendsechs, ne? Diese Debatte um um Online-Durchsuchung, Hacken von von Endgeräten ähm und seitdem äh
letztlich entziehen sich da die Akteure jeder Rationalität,
Auch zum Beispiel diese Millionen, die auf das BKA geworfen wurden, um Quellentickerüt zu ermöglichen und nach allem, was man hört, können die damit Windows, Desktops attackieren, ne, was jetzt
Offenbar nicht mehr das Problem ist bei der verschlüsselten Kommunikation. Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Drogendiener jagen will, dann haben die halt im Zweifel iPhones und nutzen Facetime und dann kann ich's mir mal schenken mit meinem Windows Explor,
Ja, also umragiert das nur auf den Punkt zu bringen. Und trotzdem werden Millionen auf das BKA geworfen, um den sogenannten Bundestrojaner äh dem BKA Trojaner zu entwickeln. Das ist das ist also aus meiner Sicht aus äh äh jetzt gar nicht mal unbedingt als Jurist einfach nur so als Bürger, der sich überlegt, was ist sinnvolles
äh verwenden von Staatskohle, ne?
Kriege ich da die Krise? Weil ich einfach, nein, ich verstehe den Impuls zu sagen, wir müssen in die Endgeräte, dass man das als Kriminalist möchte, ja? Das kann ich noch nachvollziehen. Aber dann muss man doch so rational sein und sagen, das werden wir mit
unseren sehr beschränkten technischen und finanziellen Möglichkeiten ohnehin höchstens in Ausnahmefällen hinkriegen, dann können wir das doch auch einfach mal lassen.
Trotzdem wird's ähm
sieht es äh international auch nicht gerade so aus, als ob sich das alles verbessert. Äh gerade jetzt äh Obama hat ja nun in den letzten Wochen auch nochmal angekündigt, dass er ja jetzt auch Vergeltungsmaßnahmen einleitet, digitaler Natur, nicht über alle äh wird
werden, man weißt halt nicht, was da jetzt gelaufen ist, man weiß auch nicht, ob das jetzt einfach nur dicke Hose war oder so, aber ähm,
schauen, schauen wir doch mal in die Vergangenheit, ja? Als im Jahre zwanzig dreiundzwanzig, der erste große äh digitale Weltkrieg ausbrach und das erste Mal irgendwie äh
alles äh zusammen äh fiel und man dann dachte, man hätte ja schon äh daraus gelernt, aber dann leider am neunzehnten Januar zwanzig achtunddreißig als Unique-Zeit äh umkipp
irgendwie äh alle Sicherheitssysteme,
gehebelt wurden und sich alle nochmal so richtig die Kante gegeben haben, ne? Dann dauerte es erst bis äh zwanzig zweiundvierzig, als dann endlich die digitale Cyber-UNO gegründet wurde und man sich endlich mal drauf geeinigt hat, dass.
An dieser Stelle im Netz einfach eine Nichtsangriffszone brauchen, um irgendwie äh klarzukommen auf diesem Planeten, aber das ist sozusagen evolutionärer Schritt, der noch vor uns liegt, ja, äh erinnern wir uns, äh das ist immer noch alles Neuland
und ich glaube es wird erstmal auch noch eine Weile noch ein bisschen schlimmer werden, bevor es wieder besser wird.
Ja. Aber wenn ich da nochmal einmal die Meta-Ebene, das ist so ein schönes Wort, die Meta-Ebene beklettern darf, glaubt ihr eigentlich, dass es
Mittelfristig eine Chance gibt, dass im politischen Feld, ich sage mal, Cyberkompetenz anwächst.
Schaffen wir das, dass im Bundestag, sagen wir mal, jedenfalls eine kritische Masse an Leuten sitzt in allen Parteien, die sagen wir mal wenigstens die technischen Grundlagen, soweit versteht, dass ihre verantwortliche Entscheidungen treffen können. Also ich bin, ich bin, muss man sagen, auch wirklich total gebranntes Kind durch diese WLAN-Debatte, störerhaf.
Also da habe ich äh da habe ich einfach so viel Bullshit gehört äh aus den meisten Parteien, dass ich da war ich wirklich verzweifelt, das muss ich so offen sagen, das hat man glaube ich auch in unserem Podcast gehört. Äh das war so irrational, was da gelaufen ist. Insbesondere von der GroKo, dass ich wirklich
ne? Ähm das war vielleicht aber auch ein Tiefpunkt der parlamentarischen Debatte. Ich meine, Linus, du bist ja über den Club relativ häufig auch so befasst mit Anhörung. Denkt dir der bestehende Hoffnung, sieht man deine Tendenz zum Besseren? Was kann man tun.
Also ich glaube insbesondere was jetzt hier dieses Hybernummer angeht, ne, ist das äh deshalb ein bisschen schwierig, weil ähm,
da nicht nur vielleicht eine allgemeine äh mangelnde Kompetenz jetzt irgendwie was Computer und Netze und so weiter angeht oder Hacking,
mit reinspielt, sondern eben auch das militärische Denken.
Man eben davon ausgeht, äh also dieses Argument, dass ich sage, du diese Unsicherheit, dass wenn du das machst, äh oder dann können die anderen das auch machen, dass die sagen so, ja ja genau, deshalb holen wir uns eben einfach mehr Atomwaffen
ne? Also die die Rüstungs äh
die Idee der Rüstung und die Idee der Abschränkung äh bei militärisch oder die Idee des militärischen Konfliktes unterliegt nochmal
marginal und ganz vorsichtig und anderen Prinzipien
hier zu einer Verwechselung äh motivieren ähm und deswegen glaube ich, dass äh es tatsächlich erstmal die nächsten Jahre ein bisschen in diese Cyber-War-Sache Richtung gehen wird,
Ähm.
Um man da weiterhin so auch ja meditaristisch dann tatsächlich denken wird ähm und ich hoffe, dass relativ früh die Einsicht kommt, dass es eben
keine so gute Idee ist. Und zwar für alle Beteiligten, ne? Dass man so sagt, es ist also genauso wie,
wie wie man hoffentlich vielleicht irgendwann mal die Einsicht kriegt, dass es für alle Beteiligten eine schlechte Idee ist äh mit nuklearen Waffen überhaupt rumzufuchte.
Ja, also das mit den mit den nuklearen Waffen ist dann glaube ich insofern spezielles ähm Problem, wenn man.
Auch ein ist auch äh also ich möchte,
ganz kurze, bevor ich jetzt, bevor es nachher heißt, der Neumann vergleicht äh Cyberwaffen mit Atombomben. Nein, also es äh ich habe ja darauf hingewiesen, sind äh sind sehr schlechte Vergleiche, die die man hier auch hier in viel auf vielen Ehen nicht zulässig sind. Sorry, das.
Klar. Nee, aber ähm was ich sagen wollte, ist gerade, ich finde, dass diese Nuklear, dieser Nuklearvergleich, vor allem das Problem hat, dass es dass man ja zumindest das valide Argument machen kann
dass dieses berühmte Gleichgewicht des Schreckens auch eine stabilisierende Wirkung hatte. Aber ich finde, man kann äh wenn man im Bereich ABC Waffen guckt
durchaus eine ganze Menge lernen, denn Stichwort Chemiewaffen, ne?
Da haben wir Deutschen ja mal wieder historisch äh ein quasi uns einen kleinen Orden an die Brust zu heften, weil wir nämlich äh die ersten Chemiewaffen hier eingesetzt haben im ersten Weltkrieg und komischerweise nicht auf den Gedanken gekommen sind, dass die anderen selbstverständlich genau dieselben Waffen haben oder noch viel furchtbarere Chemikalien entwickeln und so entwickelte sich im ersten Weltkrieg dann eben dieser Gaskrieg
Aber,
Es gibt da auch durchaus was Positives zu vermelden, denn die Menschheit hat ja im Großen und Ganzen eingesehen, dass das mit Chemiewaffen echt eine richtig schlechte Idee ist. Und im Großen und Ganzen funktioniert es ja, dass wir zwar furchtbare, bewaffnete Konflikte austragen, aber normalerweise
ohne Chemiewaffen. Es gibt natürlich immer wieder Ausreißer. Äh es hat nicht völlig geklappt, es gibt immer noch Asenale,
Aber sie werden kleiner und die Einsätze gehen doch soweit ich das sehe deutlich zurück, ne? Insofern vielleicht ist das mit den Chemiewaffen so ein Beispiel, dass auch Hoffnung machen kann, dass man das mit den Zahlbarwaffen
besser auch lassen so.
Meine Sorge mit den Cyberwaffen ist, dass es, dass es einige Länder gibt, die da enorme Kompetenzen aufgebaut haben und wenn die diese kompeten
nutzen, können sie damit auch äh international enorme äh Einflussnahme entfalten, ne?
Du meinst jetzt Taylor Access Operations von der NSA.
Nehmen wir nehmen wir die, nehmen wir die USA, nehmen wir äh Russland, nehmen wir China,
äh die haben da unter Umständen enormes Potential mit mit Hilfe von Hacking sage ich mal die Vorherrscherstellung äh für für vielleicht mehrere Jahrzehnte einfach nochmal zu sichern
die werden aus ihrer Stadt Raison diesem Potenzial nicht unbedingt widerstehen. Ich glaube aber, dass die Ausnutzung von
von das ist eigentlich eine These, die ich immer vertrete, die Ausnutzung sogenannter Cyberwaffen wird viel mehr im Rahmen der Spionage sinnvoll sein
als im Rahmen der Sabotage,
und ich denke, wir werden also viel weiterhin viele Spionage äh Spionageakte sehen ähm und vom und hoffentlich möglichst wenige Sabotageakte.
Mit anderen Worten.
Fast einmal aufgemacht wird. Ähm dann äh geht's echt rund. Und ich vermute so von dem, was ich technisch sehe, äh dass der Grund dafür,
eher darin liegt, dass es bisher auch keiner wollte, beziehungsweise den Beteiligten klar war, dass ähm.
Sie sich selber auch nur eingeschränkt schützen können. Also ich habe, man könnte sein, dass sie, ich, ich glaube, es gibt so ein unausgesprochenen Nichtangriffspakt,
was was kritische Infrastrukturen an.
Das wäre so ein bisschen dasselbe wie bei der bei den Atomwaffen, ne, dass man im Grunde sagt, hey, wenn wir jetzt hier anfangen, Moskau wegzupusten, äh dann sieht's halt für New York auch nicht gut aus, ne?
Also es ist echt ich könnte mir echt, also es ist relativ, was ich so sehe an an technischer Reife jetzt wirklich nicht besonders schwer und man würde sich
man würde sich vorstellen, dass wenn es jemand darauf anlegt, äh da auch was so doch signifikante Ausfälle herbeigeführt werden können,
ne? Also als Beispiel, ne, wenn du neunhunderttausend Telekom-Router aus aus Versehen abschießen kannst, dann kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen, wie das äh wie das in anderen Bereichen aussieht. Und ich vermute
also meine meine Theorie ist bis jetzt, wollte keiner diese Büchse der Pandora öffnen.
Ähm wahrscheinlich, weil es äh noch keine Motivation gab, wo das einen strategischen Vorteil in der Auseinandersetzung gebracht hätte.
So ein Ausfall herbeizuführen und zweitens, weil man sich überlegt, nee, wahrscheinlich geht das schief,
da sind wir ähnlich verwundbar, ähm! Das Attributspiel ist natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, dass man da eine Kugel ins Rollen bringen kann. Ähm! Dieses Attributspiel hat natürlich auch den Nachteil, wenn jetzt, also ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendwo Hacking passiert, werden alle sofort sagen, war der Russe, ne?
Vor drei Jahren war es noch der Chinese. Ähm war sonnenklar, alles Hacking kommt aus China, jetzt kommt's gerade aus Russland und ähm.
Vielleicht auch bald aus Syrien, ne? Wer weiß das? Die sollen ja eine ziemlich gute Cyber-Einheit haben, ne?
Serien Cyberarme oder wie das sein? Nee, da wird.
Die haben jetzt vielleicht einen ziemlich schlechten Ablenk zur Zeit, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ich glaube, dass da gerade, ich glaube, da wird gerade auch so noch ein bisschen wahrscheinlich hinter den Türen einfach eroiert, was man so machen kann,
Also ich ihr hattet ja in der Lage auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass ihr erstmal wahrscheinlich der Tee der Hypothese Glauben schenkt, dass äh dass diese E-Mail-Leaks dann in ihrer Einseitigkeit dann doch unter Umständen,
'ne russische Interessenskomponente gehabt haben könnten.
Bei mir fehlen da einfach irgendwelche von technischer Perspektive irgendwelche Beweise für. Ähm aber manchmal ist es, ist es eben vielleicht auch.
Etwas einfacher, als man es sich vorstellt, aber das Problem ist ja eben.
Mit diesem Zurückcybern, ne? Also Putin steht hier die ganze Zeit da, sagte, ich habe nichts gemacht, weiß überhaupt nicht, wovon sie wovon hier die Rede ist. Lass uns doch bitte in Ruhe, ne?
Das kann der offenbar äh spielen. Und da haben wir in der letzten Sendung ja auch drüber philosophiert, ob denn vielleicht die US-Geheimdienste Wissen haben.
Darüber, dass es solche Order gab oder nicht.
Aber wenn sie dieses Wissen haben, dann auch durch Hacking und nicht äh durch Forensik. Also es ist irgendwie ein ein komisches Spiel, was sich so äh und ich weiß noch nicht genau, in welcher Richtung sich das entwickeln wird, aber man wird hier so ein bisschen diese
diese Kaltkriegsanalogien auf mittelfristig jetzt erstmal nicht los, nicht nur wegen der Beteiligten, sondern eben auch, weil vieles eben im im Dunklen passieren kann und äh diese Attribute eben ein ein massives Problem dar
eld.
Ich denke jetzt sind wir mal zum Ende gekommen, oder?
Genau. Und äh deswegen äh danke ich an dieser Stelle dem Wintermud, dem habe ich vergessen in der letzten Sendung zu danken.
Wintermut.
Ja, das sind, also interviewt ist, äh, habe ich hier, glaube ich, schon mehrmals erwähnt. Ähm CCC, der Erfinder dieses GroKo-Logos,
und er hat mir beim Kongress eine Fahne geschenkt mit den großen Koalitionsfahne.
Hängt jetzt im Berliner CC, weil die wollte ich nicht äh die wollte ich nicht, weil für mich alleine haben, um mich dran zu erfreuen. Ähm außerdem David Thomas Jan, Markus, Benjamin und Holger.
Und wir danken dem Ulf fürs Kommen.
Ja, ich danke für die Einladung. Et war mir eine Freude gewesen, ne.
Ihr habt ja gestern erst eure Sendung aufgenommen, ne? Also es war jetzt so.
Es war so ein Marathon.
Genau, aber es ist schon wieder bringen ja auch wahrscheinlich genauso viel Zeit auf wie ihr, ne? Ja, ja, klar. Ist schon.
Ja, ja klar, ne? Podcasten ist äh ist zwar wunderschön, aber es ist noch echt Arbeit, das muss man, muss.
Man denkt nur die die Sendungsvorbereitung und so das ist schon äh nennenswerte Arbeit. Macht aber Spaß.
Macht sehr viel Spaß und es ist und es ist wichtig, klar, jetzt mal ganz mit einer Bescheidenheit ist, glaube ich, echt wichtig äh für die Demokratie, dass wir solche Diskursräume haben, das glaube ich schon, ganz ehrlich, ist auch für mich einen der Motivationen, diesen Podcast mitzumachen. Also diesen, aber auch unseren eigenen, ja.
Ich denke auch, dass wir da.
Gut dran getan haben, diese Diskussionsräume relativ früh auch aufzumachen. Ich blicke schon ein wenig mit Krausen, bis wir so ein Breitbadphänomen auch äh in der Podcast-Landschaft haben,
ähm ähnlich äh also sicherlich wird sich nicht alles, was so derzeit im geschriebenen Web äh machen lässt zu übertragen, aber wenn man da mal auch in die USA schaut, welche Rolle Radio und rechtsorientierte,
Nachrichtenverbreitung da schon seit langen, langen Zeiten auch hat, ja? Äh das ist also der,
nicht vorbeigehen so, ne? Und da muss man sich natürlich jetzt auch wappnen
der Ton hier vielleicht auch mal etwas rauer wird, von daher ist es auch sehr angemessen, vielleicht zumindest in der Szene, die bisher am Start ist, da auch schon ähm früh drauf äh achten, ja, dass man hier ähm
Einerseits den richtigen Umgang mit der Community pflegt, vielleicht auch die Community von vornherein auch schon mal den richtigen Umgang pflegt, dass wir das, was wir hier eigentlich wertschätzen und hochhalten, nämlich äh die äh
Tierung von Meinung, ja, aber auch die klare Unterscheidung von Einflussnahme und und und Debatte, äh dass das alles sehr wach beobachtet und gut getrennt wird und dass man hier auch auf einen gut
achtet. Wir machen das mal.
Ja, das wäre schön, wenn wir uns das hier halbwegs von den Hetzern freihalten.
Jetzt können wir das noch sagen, am sechzehnten Januar.
Sechzehnten Januar machen wir nur noch, aber wenn du noch Fake News.
Kurz bevor alles ganz schlimm.
Na. Eine schöne Woche.
Genau.
Danke Ulf und auf Wiederhören.
Ja, tschüss.